everybody yeah I had to skip the sea thing
today sorry in fact
I don't think we're going to be doing like
we're just getting Rhapsody up and go right
into the Google to the community stuff
I'm sorry to say that but it's just not
happening
it's not relevant to what I'm doing right
now so
and I need to get the Boost stuff done
before I get to see stuff done
and we've only got like one more week so
reschedule leave that book where it is
and I'm really really really focusing on the
yellow propagations boots for kubernetes
this is like super important is more
important than the sea stuff unfortunately
for over all the time to do so
so you just going to see me doing NFL
smelting and stuff like that effect
I don't know I'm
I love this see stuff but it's we're really
paying for it or we're paying for it in
terms of time
I would really like to turn up the
infrastructure engineering time and
focus on that
picture of the 2020 boost man that's an old
one 2021 Bruce has newer stuff but I guess
you can go to the 2020 as well
I feel like this counters going to change
the fact I've I know it is
and this is what we're going to do an FS
today so get your work there is so much shit
to learn for infrastructure engineering
and it is so totally critical to learn it
that spending time on c as cool as it is has
got to be
a secondary activity I can't be a primary
activity here it can't I know she helps
understand the system calls and everything
but we but not 6 weeks of C
so I don't know that's going to be tough I
mean
maybe six weeks ago I don't know maybe 6
weeks of it there's just too much to do and
she helps you understand a computer excetera
excetera
so I really want it I really want to make a
full 18 weeks on infrastructure engineering
and I had to meet infrastructure engineering
includes communities
I'm trying to think here
I don't even know if I can receive enough
time to go Python and JavaScript programming
as well as all the other stuff you know what
we should probably do see in there as well
and the universe
we should do if I want to see is it's not
even worth covering see unless you cover C
pointers
if you don't cover a c pointer your kind of
in trouble right
so
I don't know what we'll do some other stuff
here
I keep feeling like I should say I should
specialize on security and infrastructure
and then I should have enough applications
development to understand the applications
that you're going to be dealing with
and I guess Tracy stuff like that right
and you can learn the system calls without
knowing all of the sea you can just look him
up
and other people cover security they already
covered in rights of first of all I'm going
to do this
now put this year December 17th
now this is another 6
I think that's the thing to do
him
I mean it really does take almost a full
year to do this shit
the reason I feel like this is the way to do
this is because this is the stuff I know
that I do everyday this see stuff is
there's no Crossover with the see stuff in
it so I feel like it's better it's more
mentoring if I if I do stuff that I cover
and work with every fucking day if I try to
cover security analyst stuff it would just
be like a lights you know
topic on it because I like it
how to get higher this is stuff I or can we
not working on resumes and stuff that needs
to be done
yeah
if we take out 4 weeks of this we can finish
it by the end of the
of the year how's it going to bogus bogus
are bagasara
I think I want to do that I think I'm going
to put get the gig I want to forget the gig
over Christmas
it seems to be the Christmas thing is he
still be there
the Christmas break thing we need to do
beginner boost and infrastructure back to
back to the people who want to go deep into
a can
it feels right that feels like the right
thing to do it feels like the right thing to
do
another thing to do is I'm going to swap
Securities application developer and
administrator hey expert team I'm going to
swap application developer in administrator
because even though the application
developer test is lighter
the
knowing how to do the administration so we
can set up your kubernetes cluster first and
then write applications for it
no Maybe not maybe we do mini Cube first
because then people the application
developer boost is actually that covers the
why of kubernetes was like why do you give a
shit why do you care if I can raise what can
I do for you and your company well you know
and then we'd probably have people who want
to get going and deploy their applications
get ready so we can communicate applications
development
and then oh
all right so then they want to we need we
need
Majic paints
yeah when you change the dates I know I'm
not starting it really I'm kind of I kind of
just just thinking out loud I'll be up again
late doing and coding stuff
their official website of course they did
oh I do like that yep
thank you for somebody finally calling that
out that's actually will read the first
paragraph
i s
I don't know that's what I've been wondering
I think
I started out going that way but
I feel like if we don't show applications
development activities people aren't going
to give a shit about how to administer it
and if we jump in and start talking about
storage classes going to be like why do I
care you know
yeah the library to put that in there it's
probably a true it would be about right
yeah that's just regular for the rescue knee
Frank M
so I think I think we're going to stay with
application development first
C K & c k s in hand without Administration
without security is you subtly
yeah well we definitely have to seek a sign
I am to guess I just
what if we combine them all and we just put
a kubernetes boost and we say look by the
end of this you should be able to get
cuz here's the problem there's tons of
overlap between the administrator and the
application developers though
I think if we just did infrastructure
engineering which includes devops sort of
immature treasure is primary virtualization
introduction containerization and then we do
a doctor in kubernetes boost no containers
and communities that's what we need to do
when you do containers in kubernetes
and you call a devops if you want but I
don't give a shit that's not what I'm going
to call
because that you know I don't think we
should break them out I think I don't think
we should
this is going to be that's going to be like
so that includes docker-compose dockerfile
ronettis how to make images white we do with
images where you would put the images it
doesn't have any virtualization stuff so
infrastructure engineering is going to be
primarily based on servers like Hardware
servers and virtualization servers and
cremation container is like just that right
you could argue that being a boost is like
traditional stuff when you have just a
single multi-user server
yeah I think that's the way to go
like I said it's just going to simplify
things like so much
and then I then I don't have to stress about
it I've been stressing about
covering things that are not in my core
interests because I'm not doing them all the
time like see
and I just it's just hard for me to cut chop
chop out time for it because I know it's a
distraction from the other stuff I need to
learn
you know it's fun and it's just really nice
instructional and it helps to understand a
computer and all that
the number for CK over Stacy card so far
right now I have I mean at the beginning of
the year I did nothing but ckad I did
development stuff because we're due for Hub
that's where the whole that's and then I did
services to understand how to make an
application in kubernetes yet so
yeah
or did it stretches out of them know I don't
I've been outside a few times actually
that's there's a data structures of course
inside of my and I never will cover that
I want time I've tried I've just got have
decided to go really really deep into
infrastructure and operations and to have
more of a a 40-60 split into a terms of
coding to the operations
I am Frank loves to tell me that I suck at
programming
and it's true it's true I suck at
programming compared to people who could all
the time
I also don't think it's required to learn
data structures and algorithms at all
it might help you as a software engineer but
the truth is I'm not Preparing People for
software engineering careers I've had a very
successful software engineering career I did
yeah if you're majoring Matheny eye then go
to machine learning and this is not the
place for you this is the place to come when
you want to learn how to use the best tools
that are going to get you in and help you be
a fish are you want to build your own lab or
you want to and I do stuff like that he
wanted you want the the infrastructure to
run your your your software on butt
I've always been
it is funny because I'm about to take this
but when it comes to coding and engineering
and operations I really am
and yeah I don't think this
you want to know that stuff but I can't come
to my degree is absolutely can't is kind of
stupid
I do not work stuff yeah yeah even in
there's no there's no secret that covers it
there's no debris that covers infrastructure
engineering. I have never seen a degree on
planet Earth on in any country that covers
enter for infrastructure engineering topics
at all
I don't they just don't take cover it it's
not too easy if you fucking kidding me
you've been paying attention
dude if you think setting up your own
carre's cluster on your own operations in
your own storage classes and everything is
easy and that's why I called just don't
cover it
I think you're fucking fool that is not the
reason they don't cover it the reason I will
cover it is because it's practical it's not
theoretical and quality is the only cover
theoretical ship if they don't cover
practical stuff let's go to Community
College to get an engineering degree
what's up
I yeah okay
no I'm in I just woke up you know what that
means
give her my brain is on fire and I got to do
brain stuff I see that
no you and your timing
what was I thinking of I can't even remember
what was on my brain
I love you what are you doing okay
okay
boy oh boy I literally can't think about I
cannot remember a single thing I was
thinking before that
that's miss my coffee
what's the name of your face any theories of
his offer engineering degrees
is useless rent not even worth it 3 yeah
yeah and operations is that's my my number
one complain about education education is
all theoretical almost all of it
they never teach you why
you need to learn calculus or why you need
to learn history or why chemistry all right
you know if people have to find their own
applications of the Y
and Anna
my wife doesn't feel bad I'll be back
I said I was starting soon online
degrees out of University in the Portuguese
iMac I'm back
accreditation
I talked about the accreditation problem
before colleges can't keep up
if they teach Theory they can get accredited
because the curriculum doesn't change
if they try to teach practical application
was changes every fucking day they can never
keep up and they can't get accredited
that's exactly the problem the whole
education system is totally broken because
of that
all right
an investment banker in the same time to
test Coronavirus where do that
I thought about removing bigger from the
bigger from the the title of the labs
because it's really not about vagrant it's
about how to set up an FS that's what is
about
and you can't test setting up and it says
without a virtual machine and you can't
setup a virtual machine I mean I guess you
could do it from the command line using VBA
box manager or something like that
to create a new disk cell
I got one more day to fix your I need to
move this date in to here just bear with me
for a second
Cal
I mean this is probably be
Cal 2022
not the whole year there we go
mention movie in June we have January so if
we have
it is a weird September September 3rd
levitate for shave 4 weeks from January 28th
we get we go back to
what is a Sea Ray 2028
oh that's next year ice 123 yeah okay
give me an exam
Embrace bootcamps yeah because the boot
camps can teach fast
delete 234 that would mean December
December 31st be the last one that's
actually perfect
I change this to be September 3rd
to December 31st
yeah a lot of a lot of colleges don't know
they don't know the Practical part of it cuz
it never done it
enter the beautiful intelligent people who
have no practical application for this it's
up to 13th Street
but I think it's really broken actually and
I'm 100% practical too much so I would
rather fail and fail and fail and fail and
fail then read the document about why I
should be that way and that's actually the
natural way to learn things that's how
nature Works literally but I don't know if
it's the best way I know
and then we do this one it'll be January
I'm in January is a good thing at at like
this a lot this is like almost like it's
like meant to be because it's like it makes
getting the job the first thing you think
about a January which is always good so in
January we talked about getting jobs
ripe and
Hickory for sale 1815 2229
I just make any sense a 22
I might have that wrong
2 January 2020
am I so that's I did this right all right so
January 7th to 20th of night
7 Henry 2020 resumes and stuff
and talk to her recruiters excetera
what's a what's a Lennox beginner boost
intersection you can put the system in there
get the gig containers Community Co-op
yep and then
I feel like you can apply for jobs with just
having the Linux infrastructure stuff if you
just had to learn all the stuff from the
Linux and a structure boost you would
seriously you'd be definitely employable
that point may be employable after the Linux
boost
I just dropped him a hiking streams
I dropped the package from just no time we
can cover Security in the containers and
infrastructure we're going to cover security
all along the way here I'm going to talk
about pentesting career with certification
to get hats and I'm going to spend time and
hack the Box probably not probably not and
if I do it's going to be related to
infrastructure it'll be something I do
instead of gaming you know me something I do
instead of gaming because
there's just not enough time this is not a
time I love security topics but but they are
not they're not quarter what I do you know
what I mean so with that stuff include so I
can raise security right truth is is it if
you'd if you understand the stuff that I'm
doing you know how to finish all of your
track meet at the Box in things like that
because you can figure it out
he actually has an assigned nice Honeywell
I think security is kind of implicit in
understanding that how the core
infrastructure works the only thing that's
not here in terms of like the security that
I would be interesting would be forensics
and that would require require deep level C
knowledge and stuff in and I I don't want to
cover it I like it it's interesting stuff
but it's not practical
and there's not enough people to cover it
this is what nobody is covering on stream
right nobody except for had Tanis had Tanis
is the only person on Twitch and YouTube
that I know of who is covering
you know General Enterprise infrastructure
engineering topics and go get your 8 plus
from the guy on YouTube if you want to you
can do it with me but there's nobody
covering it so I think the reason that I'm
going to dwelling on this little bit more
into today is because
today is because this content is just not
there it's not covered
zone 6 and architect nice sourcing
procurement
it's a great that would be best bath like
service stations I think he's probably that
I would if I were going to look I am not a
security person you want to go ask somebody
in the industry is insecurity but I
seriously studied security at the beginning
of 2020 2021 actually 2020 if you need 2020
I seriously studied all of them were passing
security and stuff before I made a decision
I actually decided not to go to security
because it's 50% report writing at least
most of the security jobs professional jobs
I decided I wanted to be Hands-On and
infrastructure all the time 24 7 and there's
more opportunity for that infrastructure
engineering and communities in devops in
that kind of thing that you're you're
dealing with tag all the time you're not
you're not writing reports we have a stand
up every day and that's it but I must not
like riding I did not want to do that as
part of my job so I avoided security is a
career path
is mean I don't like security doesn't mean I
don't hack in my spare time I could return
and one thing I completed out of that is
there is two paths in Security in general if
you want to be a Hands-On security is
actually three there's the pie-in-the-sky
You Know Chief security operations the cissp
kind of people that set security policy and
they don't do any hacking at all they just
go to meetings and talk about how everybody
should be more secure and they said policies
that make people and make make power points
and then you have the the pentesters who are
hacking things all the time and writing
reports about it is a freelance version of
that where they're doing the same thing I
tell me what I just did and there's some a
vulnerability so they can assess and then
get the money and then you have a defensive
people that are constantly striving stuff
down which is just sister was just systems
Administration I did that technically I
qualified as a security expert while I was
in a medium because I was writing systems on
its software and then they would patch holes
in the systems in order to prevent them from
getting hacked that's a security profession
itself so it's just a ministration know the
reason I'm not focusing on security
specifically here because
you did a good infrastructure engineering is
security blue blue team defensive security
is built into your job offensive security
isn't so much other than as a method for
finding out what what's week when I get some
money I know I know but I know those power
points are important and I'm not have been
trying to attack anybody I'm just telling
you this not the job I want
yeah
I'm not look I'm not taking anybody's career
I'm telling you what the career is if you
want to write if you want to do a lot of
Russians and Consulting and stuff like that
and it's your gig then that's that's very
high by the way to do that
and do that I would get the cissp out of
work towards getting it yet you can't even
get it until you get one of the Lesser
certificates that's been blessed by the
organisation and then you have to climb the
ladder and you put your time and you going
to go to years time and on to get it and
then you can eventually get it you can be
you know the executive the the other
the Inn in there then there's like the
researchers who I spend all their time in
the lab just like I mostly just finding
zero-day bugs and stuff like that and doing
forensic science if it's already been busted
and everything and we have people in here
doctor Professor whatever the fuck that
persons are usually drunk when they're here
claims to do forensic I know we have at
least at least at least four people who work
probably in some military government
capacity and and they they do all kinds of
the problem with that path with that path
you have to have certificates in your degree
and so w makes the most sense of humor
American to do that you can get you can get
a master's in cyber security for under
$6,000 doing W-4 me to credit University
that comes with 25 industry certificates for
security by default as including the price
and I have nothing to do with w
there are other streamers who do they get
paid crazy gobs of money for sponsoring them
I don't but I still feel like that's the
best path if you want to go into security
and you want a traditional role and it
conservative organization like the military
military or NSA or something like that they
have high high degree requirements for
certificates if you want to work for a you
know kind of a cooler like if security or
one of these firms out there
one of these firms out there that does
security you know as by contract they they
they make fun of people who get certificates
and of the only certificates they actually
there's actually a date make a joke about on
the job application page on S security and
the only one they really care about is osep
and that's the one I was searching to get so
my conclusion when I was going to see her a
bath cuz I wanted to be an attempt to
offensive security and then I wanted to
Moonlight on the side to make money one way
or another and I
I was seeking to get the oscp which is
really expensive and hard to get and and and
then to supplement that with you know just
just getting into a CPU will get you in the
door almost anywhere if you want to work
like that
so
somebody on the Nets that's why I'm saying
we probably will talk about security as a
profession we talked we talked about get the
gig I have heard at least three times in
this chat hey thanks how's it going at work
I haven't at least three times in this chat
I have heard people say
one day I was assisting ministrator and then
my manager came to me and pointed at me and
said you're now a security analyst
an easy filter absolutely severe weather is
helping HR determine absolutely
so the reason that I'm dropping security as
an official Focus here is I tell you this if
you can do everything in the Linux boost and
you know that comparison communities and
infrastructure engineering
and you're a decent system in which is an
old term that so matters
you can do security you can do security all
you have to do is spend like in a three or
four months going into the the methods of
attack and it and I also said that the
reason that so many systems just get retitle
the security people is because they're
already doing the job they're already did
you know there are any patching systems
already and I'm looking for vulnerabilities
know what they're not actively attacking
things so that's something they might have
to learn so my point is is that you can
easily transition from
Nutrisystem administration's and
infrastructure engineering into into into
security and like it into like a little more
security prioritize bill
how do I get to cks the community security I
could I could craft a career that's just
focus on community security only just that
because that's the number I was at Defcon 3
keynote presentation this year
so people breaking it's the hot new thing is
to break into careers clusters
but if you don't know how it came right
across their works are you don't know how
NFS works or any of these things that could
raise depends on you have no hope of being a
security expert in that field he's going to
have it works so first seek to understand
how it works that's all I hacker is somebody
who understands how it works Darlene has a
famous quote of mr. robot she goes given
enough time and white papers I can own that
bitch or something like that she can white
papers is the other official documentation
on how something works and that's that's the
biggest of all is just being able to really
dive in and understand how the system works
and see its flaws are just the security
people are just glorified testers they're
really really amazing that's why they called
pentesters but they're just really really
amazing testers who can see all the angles
on a thing and testing by itself as a career
that doesn't have a title these days in QA
engineer as it's not a title that you can
really find it's kind of sad actually
I haven't searched on indeed but I would be
challenged to find if you can if you can
even find anything on that particular topic
I don't think you can
so so nice peter boost infrastructure
engineering and then had to get to dig that
that is the new the new thing
I'm going to say that that makes me feel
better because I gives me more time to carve
should out even if you don't get formal with
it it'll just give us a topic to cover and
we can do it like we did last time it is
kind of weird anticlea let the topics blow
and try to try to make sure they'll fit
within the amount of time 18 weeks I was
probably enough time to learn everything
that we need to do
that we need to do it in a festive this
stuff goes with infrastructure engineering
May detect feels who were searched have
little impact on her guards HR yeah
absolutely yeah it was Abella purse
absolutely have no if I was available I
would not get a cert
the me on actively tells people not to get
certs any teaching web Developers
you're an engineer or a security person it's
different I did a whole thing of this
I did a whole videos how do I certify go
watch that's an hour long thing I made a
pretty graph
it's specifically about that topic so I got
to get better at just sending people to my
videos and then
and then not not wasting too much time
talking about it over and over and over
again
is it again if I thought yeah red flag with
developers yam
yeah I read that very fact
yeah I read that I read that from Gail
actually that you were at the cracking the
coding interview book
you don't invite me to another reason for
this to me to Frankel love this
you know it's a different world to get to
get a purely software engineering
programming job is 100% different career
path then going into operations it's totally
different the way you get the job the the
type of things you have to do to create
trust so when I reasons you're seeing me
kind of shift away and it's I mean you know
Frank says I'm a horrible program or well
you know I am so
you know I'm playing good I can get if I
have had programming jobs where I have made
you know well well into the six-figure range
and
so I know I can do it but I think they think
I'm kind of coming to terms with his I've
always been an operations hacker who happens
to have coding skills
it just so happens that my coding skills
one day are better than the operation skills
and if you spend all their time on coding
than your operation skills get soft as I
have been experiencing last 3 days not
knowing how to set up NFS and having to look
up how to set up an exports file is the most
fucking embarrassing thing because I used to
know the shit I just know it like the back
of my hand is kind of thing I could just
like pull it out anytime and you can't do
everything so you have to decide how you're
going to break down yourself and so I'm
going to spend less time on so we're going
to Learn Python JavaScript we don't have a
code in Python JavaScript go and a little
bit of sea during the Olympics be in a
booster we're going to learn enough coding
to be dangerous that's the point so you can
understand or seeking where you learn how to
code in order to make utilities and
understand how software works it's super
important that you get that as an operations
person but if we're learning how to code in
order to under to seek to understand into
Annalise software for vulnerabilities and to
see how it works as a much different goal
than learning some shity day today
now everything's in order to write really
intense crazy amazing software from the
beginning and design it beautifully that's a
valid goal and I love that stuff you but but
I am when I'm coming to terms with you or is
it the the method of teaching coating that I
want to really emphasize on is is making
quick and dirty fast utilities to get the
job done to hack the site or two to analyze
one mobility and understand software and
that means you need to be able to read
multiple languages is a polyglot and you
need to be mine really proficient in writing
code in those languages but you need to be
really proficient in writing code in
languages that allow automation which
includes Ruby actually affect me to put that
in there
we got to put Ruby in there we got it we got
to spend at least a small amount of time
writing Ruby because because Ruby's vagrant
and Ruby's you know Ruby's the Menace boy
database we can't skip Ruby we have to do it
now Frank might like that he's a big relief
in
it's probably gone now.
Disney products and show them an interview
and that's a question for somebody else I
don't know
Ruby's get ladder shelf to it yet it is yes
it is yeah it is you can't if we if we start
picking languages and depth of language
learning based on infrastructure engineering
jobs
earring jobs it's a much different palette
of languages right
the sea game book and review as well the
program would be like one chance decides to
feel ya
yeah what we're going to do I don't know
what we did we we we have a lot of a lot of
things on the table for the coding way to do
whatever you do probably glad that we're
going to try to throw another language
python Ruby we probably should do Pearl to
let me come on if you give me an operations
person and you can't reap roll
you know what this is I'm having a moment
here I'm having a moment here yeah
I'm having a moment because yeah
I'm having a moment here Pearl Pizzeria I
think you need to learn all for you to be
able to read it
so if we're going to teach operations
programming then having broad knowledge of
multiple languages is way more important
than in-depth knowledge of one language it's
way more important
and you know that means you need to be able
to read and write parole positives bash
python Ruby Go-Go and I actually I'm going
to say it you don't need rest too because
nothing's written in rusted that level
it's not you might want to make it a tool
and rust or something so I could see doing
that but I haven't even kissed you yet
girl uses basic Ruby to save space
yeah of course it is you're going to put in
your Journal I think it was a joke
I think the empty was drilling you know
I've never once I open an application in C
plus plus to understand it in order to do my
job
I've opened a ton of shit and see and go
knowing how to compile C code we need to
include seeing here but we don't need to
include sea to the level knowing how to
compile C code
has been a core thing for doing any kind of
Linux work at all if you wanted to Jen to
anything like that you have to know what
make is you have to know how to compile C
code you don't necessarily have to know C
code you have to know how to make C code or
C plus plus code
actually need the copy this out and put it
in that I feel good about this now I feel a
lot better it's just this just opened up a
bunch of time for us to do kind of a deeper
think so simple and the infrastructure
engineering boost we're going to we're going
to touch on compiling see applications we're
going to touch on creating a packages and
understanding the package systems of the
world RPM yum will talk about Pac-Man just
say it exists but it's not a thing it's not
an Enterprise thing at all these make to
compile I know that I was just stupid I hate
that they do but we need to know it so all
that stuff has to go in infrastructure
engineering because infrastructure
engineering is about creating it
applications installing them testing them
and stuff like that it's more about getting
the stuff to compile then it is knowing how
the code works even though a little bit of
knowing other code words make sense likes
from scratch for sure I would love to do a
Linux from scratch the gentoos actually just
as good pretty much
but but yeah and we're kind of actually
doing a Linux from scratch with Negron
greetings for fastest 400 is more valuable
to an operations of a structure engineer and
then you know learning to code in Ruby
because or anything like that because that's
the stuff for engineering task not to be
able to create your own lightweight Linux
distros is fucking crazy good as I think
there is some C and infrastructure
engineering you know there's like C for
operations and I mean and I don't think we
need to touch and see both of us if
something's been compiled a written to see
if I was supposed to be fine but very little
software for Linux is written in simplest
plus very little
yeah yes
so I feel better about this I feel better
about this can always link stuff that's fine
as long as it's not me no boobs or something
yeah I think this is much better yam
make isn't I to see anyway it's just a
number 120 people think for it come on BMT
it come on
I mean it's I agree with you but it's a
little bit pet pedantic
except for they do have a sub shell for
every line
yeah
we're not dropping see we're not dropping
see we're moving see into the infrastructure
engineering boost and we're going to learn C
and we're going to learn system calls and
we're going to estrace
because those dance and know how to make C
code right
and and I guess it's supposed to be a boost
it will say hey if you want to go over and
see you go do you know the sea the sea book
on it
mitigate containers in kubernetes
yeah I think we'll do that same
I feel like
I feel like I want to keep him in a row I
don't want to do that
ebpf yeah
yeah if you have Tracy needs to be in there
so I'm saying this this stuff that we're
talking about it's more infrastructure and
security related it's it's and it's kind of
hacker it borders on hackers hackers Ness
I like that these are building up to each
other so I'm going to do that
all right
yeah I was going to in January but I don't
think so I think we should start the new
year with containers
I think we should
hell I don't even know if we should do
getting the gig maybe we could probably do
that in like
two weeks it doesn't mean that many weeks
we can't cover curious in 6 weeks and we
can't
I'm making a Command Decision you can have
to get your own fucking job you can't we can
talk about getting a gig and getting a job
during the AMA time and help you get the job
the love to see and I yeah
well I just think that we're talking about
just knowing how to put C and I into a
system you know that's a big thing
make it a m a i think you're right yeah
how many days is 3 hours bullshitI call
bullshit
this kind of is a Lennox a sorry thing
play just a Lennox beginner bass
that's crazy funny why are you not VIP that
just made me laugh
oh my God that's funny that is why funny
if you make me laugh you get VIP very very
capricious
entertain me
communities can later well
I'm dropping JavaScript
7th grade
I think I'm going to I'm going to I think
I'm going to drop JavaScript
if you it's more important for you to learn
Ruby than JavaScript is an operations person
by far
hateful eight Chevy out yeah job in 15 hours
did you have to lie learn it in 15 hours
that's phenomenal
did you learn it that's fantastic
do to do to do I can cover very pretty cover
I think your idea using them for yours good
job Daniel
I'll make a program out of you
high tide driver how are you
I got to go anywhere that's more creative
than our mdash rfm people laughing about
that that's a nice job that's a nice joke
hey look my schedule just got a lot easier
I'm serious I'm I'm dropping I'm dropping
JavaScript
I'm dropping you off at your look you can
you can pick up JavaScript like that if you
learn how to code in review python in Pearl
no it's not it's not anywhere near modern
operations
hello what the heck does above do not run at
seriously look up your computer
your computer at one time I did actually
delete /
yes it will as long as you do it yes you
have to have to do it as rude
so
this pulling up programming I still want to
do this
but it's not core it's not core to this
we need to I don't know if we want to do
just like a generic polygon programming I
feel like we need to do
programming for operations
and we need to focus on that that's like
really important
you know
tea organizer always falls in the summer.
That's not good
I don't know if note is a part of it I don't
think it is I've never seen no use in
operations
if anybody can give me an example of node
being used in any operational capacity let
me know but there are so many other fucking
languages to learn
that I just can't imagine it
just in case we have no business being in
operational programming class
notice heavily used in what
they're just to deploy their apps that's not
operations at the devops
yeah but you look running note on a server
is fine that's that's not that's not the
point architecture right so if anybody knows
of a core tool that uses JavaScript
as its method I mean here's the thing that
we're facing today right you've got to learn
Ruby you got to learn it you got to learn
that you've got to learn Pearl and Python
and as much as I don't like any of those
yeah I mean I'm not I'm not fighting with
you by the way
omelette how much
okay I could probably figure out when and
how to eat that a p l
not app something like infrastructure yeah
no she's she's just making it just now is
she coming or twice at 10 to me first
attempts to sex and I'll just have to meet
with an omelet
she's like she's like flashing me off-screen
you guys missed that earlier you finished or
yoga
I love her so much he's so much fun but my
wife is just so hilarious you just keeps me
laughing all the time electron uses no dies
but but it's not an operations we don't do
you get a very much we used to be used to go
get together and then it was very personal
thing if if you like sitting next to
somebody in
you know what you do daily or get to think
what we do yoga together as we go out for a
date whoever day two yoga School yoga class
is actually really good video of us doing
yoga together
it says I'm on vacation because I canceled
the C-Class
it says I'm on vacation cuz I canceled the
C-Class and
I didn't know how else to do it
I realize I might be able to hit the
schedule the way I want to and get certified
as just too much to do so I have to drop a C
class in February 12th that's only two weeks
as soon as I can finish the book so I might
as well just quit the book now and keep
going on the community stuff and
infrastructure stuff and and and simplify
the counter which is where I'm still Adam
still I'm so fucking around the calendar but
I feel really good about this so
we need we need something we need a book
that's about programming for operations
in
how about we call it scripting Yo Gotti
listen to memory map
I kind of feel like we need power showing
their butt
bash python Pearl and Ruby
I mean these are the leaders right
Posh works on Lennox it does I know it's
hard as hell we saw it last year like two
years ago we were laughing all the time all
the way through it
yeah I can be in
yeah if you guys have a few questions BMT is
the person to contact
I think I think this is this is what it
comes down to
do you put Jason and emaline there I kind of
feel like they go Ruby has to be there
you know why Ruby is still a huge part of
Chef and people have shifted what are our
work we still have Chef that place you know
that we have ten thousand or more lines the
Procol that people still have to read
basically if you want to be a Linux person
you need to be able to understand the
different interpreted languages that are
used for stripping buttocks and that's
that's all I mean I'm I'm coming to terms
with this actually having gone through this
particular the vagrant stuff because vagrant
saw it you what else is all the medicine
Boyd
I don't know if I should jump ya know
somebody by now what the capacity
typical
I'm talking shit about you in French
how to say hi if you at work still probably
important for working of you
I don't think a functional programming
language has any place near here not for
this not for operations in scripting
Shopify is Ruby Ruby's everywhere Metasploit
databases is Ruby all the boot camp shirt is
in Ruby on Rails is still out there
so you know
like Nick saucer doll yeah I want to learn
French
so you can talk shit about people hey hey
hey hey for you honey thank you for that
Kyle now no I'm a nice day
and she'll bash python Ferrari we're not
going to see show cuz it's fucking dangerous
Ruby
I like I like I like how this is going and
if we keep it Linux flavored then we will
then we can get away with not putting
flowers on there cuz I mean who gives a shit
about power so I figured it if you're going
to be a hacker you have to learn I don't
want to force you any battery works
oh you should have some pretty freaky
I get a Texas and Haskell is it will fuck
maybe we need to learn Haskell on F
I mean I put scripting in here for a reason
I put scripting for a reason because
scripting is not the same
you cannot pandoxx Haskell I know I love it
and I still have my back is my single
favorite Haskell application so the only
application
hey Daniel thank you for that nursing
service dog I'll know
internationally have Saturday pop top
all right so we have been expecting a shell
and Paul got put on I think probably got
programming is probably a good separate book
this book is going to be like okay here's
how to do this book we can do a polyglot
shell scripting in scripting and I make a
new poly got programming and it can like get
into the deeper things like functional
programming so like that you know what does
it mean to compile code python python is is
there because it's a good compliment to a
judgeship if it would be great if we could
do see in here
do you know Sego Python and JavaScript
I think we should do see
I don't want to put in there because you
can't understand your computer until you
learn to see
I know but
this is this this particular class doesn't
doesn't fit anywhere in here anymore this is
a probe from Canarsie I went through the
book again review that I used to hate it I
don't think a lot of its relevant I like him
first he first as the book that we were
supposed to do right now but we're done with
it you can't understand assembly before you
going to see
yeah I think you need to learn C
and eventually
have I really want to go and see you go B on
a graduation
we need to learn go in order to understand
how software is written in the
infrastructure space
and
for activities the container Securities
boost is this the end of time
the links and Cody is going to be doing
we're going to show shell coding
yeah I don't know hey how are you doing
thank you
how's it going to be X you need to have a
boy
yeah I've been said that I've had a lot of
fun it's been really fun actually
life is been fun I go back and forth has
been really depressed other days I'm on top
of the world I feel I feel positive today
but
just up your I see ya
okay so I guess I was wondering before I
jump into the NFL smell time in Vegas
can I woke up and I was looking at the stuff
and
realization hit me that the stuff that's not
covered
is the infrastructure stuff this is the
stuff that's lacking from the internet like
good content written about infrastructure
and Lennox and operations is
is substantial Tikka t1x is substantially
missing from the internet just not there
I've searched high and low and I don't want
to throw anybody to the bus but the contents
out there is very very minimal and the the
container security stuff that's out there
and light it's done from a Mac and that's
fine but
you know containers for Alex technology. Yes
I know other technologies have it but
they're not the basis of the entire Cloud
made of Revolution Alexi is and that's when
it's only so teaching containers and
communities on a Max just makes me my skin
crawl
because it's not attacking anybody lie just
so
anyway this is this is this feels good this
feels good this feels good that's what she
said
the backing of some big Iron unisystems
everybody yeah
well it's getting more that just hear about
their their talk and could raise on the
Mainframe now
yeah it's been a lots of fun. Tell me what
have you heard about that in any official
capacity there's a lots of writing right now
on it
yeah there's there's lots of writing about
communities on on Big Iron again which is
going to be full circle as soon as
everybody's running kubernetes on on
Mainframe it'll just be so perfectly
poetically ironic
it's going to happen and all that big
processing power Office Max in Python
is there until I come out yeah yes
so anything about learning tripping like
that is that that's going to make it so
basically
this cycle this yearly cycle will make you
one fucking Kick-Ass hacker without actually
ever saying we're teaching you to be a
hacker
because you'll be understanding all the
stuff that you can use once you understand
how to deploy your own communities close to
her home you can like lunch that shitt at
the internet and do all kind of pen testing
scans which is something I want to do it
said something I haven't done yet but I'm
definitely on the way to doing it and see
what API vs. back by my friend yeah
that's what I'm saying and keep baby I can
be anything right it's coming you know
what's going
you know it's coming watch I being like
enter the game with some like massive single
solution and all that Enterprise cloud and
just like destroy red hat oh wait they are
red hat
they're you know if they put open shift on
Mainframe
yeah this was I just read about this that's
why it's that's why it's in my that's why
it's in my interests lately
I just read about this came across my feed
the other day
becoming a car that think about hockey yeah
I made a hacker's just British people
understand shit right I know how to break
down problems
yeah
Lenox I might be a cat is to tell me about
this all the time until Park clusters
working on registry holyshit a master's in
coasters in the hoods houses anymore is that
a date Nicole control planes
you racist pigs i b m
seriously don't call it Master anymore did
you see they're getting rid of the the thing
I don't have a custom running right now
I like I do I don't I don't have a class or
a nevermind
but yeah it's called you can call the
control thing they're calling it control
plane, Master as the rolls but they're
dropping Master is one of the roles in in
1.24
is asking for a friend these windows yeah
yeah I think it was over
there in 2008 throughout Microsoft Office
and they use open office now
so that's kind of cool with you cuz cuz I
want to cuz cuz I want to eat with you
oh my God you should smell this
on a cold Sunday morning is smell of an
omelette with cheese
oh my God you guys yall chat I'm going to
coerce the dog is right here in 2 seconds I
know you thought you were going to see me
stream but instead I'm going to eat the
omelette
it won't take that long am I dropping until
I thought it was still hot
so operate
how about this back at back at 3:30
I buy
alright I'm back I was good
but anyways was able to go stream about
touching you at nice ancient good job we
have to go watch you
question you should do see coding cuz I'm
not going to need to stream PC coating not
me
how about that how about we do then did you
do did you do the deal stream
encoding nice
that's great I mean this in a thing to add
anything to that I've been realizing is that
I don't have to do everything
add still stuck I did have to do everything
I did I had to give people backgrounds and
everything right but I don't have to do
anymore I can point people to data
structures and algorithms like in point
people to do you know C plus plus in Striker
or you know assembly with him also or he
doesn't scream that much anymore but you
know I'm saying and he put people at the
other stuff I'll Lesley streaming again
she's getting kind of crazy
all right so let's do other stuff
alright so so so so let's get back into some
of this other stuff since I'm now here
tell me what if you're still there too I
don't tomorrow or something we need to talk
about doing The Keg stuff
and I mean we need to get people like ready
for that kind of stuff
so let's do that
all right back to the NFS that so I'm going
to get going fast here before I get going I
just want to make sure everybody
can hear put a marker
where's my marker starting and Fs
I wish you could see the markers
let me set some goals for the day so today
today the goal is to finish setting up the
NFS client automated setup of NFS through
scripting on from the control the workers
and just have that SharePoint ready so that
we can run this big of a file and after
you're done with it you get three machines
low power machines that have and if it's
working and then you can understand how did
you send it so this lab is something that I
do hope to
expanded to something other people can do if
they want to learn it fast does it need
bigger in the name probably not in fact I
think I'm probably going to rename a bunch
of these things as just like Lavender Fest
you know and get rid of vagrant in there and
just assume that vagrant is going to be to
go to tool for provisioning virtual machines
you know I got back and forth on whether
vagrant I like it or not and use of Ruby or
not and and there's a couple of lessons
learned that I that I've made so so one of
them is learn Ruby
Ruby is still a core language for
operations type types of things
it is used in vagrant Chef Metasploit
and many and
and in many other scripted environments
it is mandatory how's it going it is
recurring Lee obvious
it is obvious to me that it must be included
in the list of essential scripting languages
for any would-be infrastructure in Virginia
so the very first cell phone we did add to
work are you silly
I love her for surform yeah I don't know if
I would ever go for that there's a couple
reasons for that
yeah that's the main reason that I have
soured on the Isle of a I love it is that
it's just not mainstream enough it's not
mainstream enough for the stuff that
operations people need to do you still need
to learn delivered because lot of the
Technologies and operations going to use it
going to be using zendan KVM and all that
stuff so you need to know it as a part of a
structure anybody should you make it your
primary driver for vagrant and terraformed
and everything else probably.
I absolutely would rather this is I'm going
to say something that's that's pretty
controversial I would rather learn Ruby and
keep it fresh and on the tip of my skill-set
than HCL
I'm not a fan of haschak work or a language
and it to the point where I would probably
actually not use it I would probably end up
using something that's not HCL
just cuz
I'm just not not a fan of it I doesn't mean
that you can't get away with it pelumi and
other things like that so there's like that
an entire group of languages you have to
learn for operations that are structured
data languages like and configuration
language is like a sauna in Yamhill and HCL
and Tamil and an XML and and properties
about those are all things that also have to
be learned as an operator so again I keep
coming back to what does an infrastructure
operations engineer who has Kick-Ass coding
skills learned as opposed to what does a
software engineer need to learn write and
and as a hacker and infrastructure engineer
you need to learn
you need to learn all of the configuration
languages on planet Earth languages are
starting to take off and infrastructure
h e HCL is is pretty is pretty, I only know
it's used in one place and hatch Carlos use
it for that okay or no your not ugly as Sin
though I didn't like it at all okay for sure
though Rico you know it's learning Rico and
it is so you know you can learn JavaScript
or you can learn Rigo
you know if you're a kubernetes person
you're going to learn Rigo's give you much
more valuable to you than JavaScript the
same nobody here has even heard of it but
it's way more more valuable
so so that's that's going to come from so
let's do this stuff is all running
I think we have already got stuff running
alright so here we have the recap what we
did
it's not like riding 10 miles of Ruby's
going to teach teach taught me we or anybody
movie
yeah I know I saw it and look up once upon a
time I knew Ruby Ruby much better than I did
now I don't know how much today but you need
to learn it in order to read it and write it
and therefore much more approachable than
the following me but wait for the ABS thing
yeah well I mean that's again as an
operations person your job is learning
configuration language is very quickly and
scripting it's it's a part of the job so you
know and then writing code that writes other
scripting code you mean that's a part of the
job it really is so and if you don't any web
stuff is because you wanted to make some
stupid graphic interface because your
manager needed it instead of a command line
tool I'll have some of you have forgotten
almost all that yeah I can write something
today I was that way with roll last year I
was at my throat Cipro for 15 years and
could not remember any of it so I still feel
like it's it's worth you know relearning it
very productive yeah me too you know I
really slammed on bigger for being so old
and using Ruby and stuff and then I looked
at you know Chef which is also old and
Amanda split so with your chances are it is
never charges are you going to run across
Ruby in some form and Baker is has been a
reminder of that for me so so let's just go
through this
this is so he's been keeping up with what
I'm doing here big breakthroughs BP here is
definitely been lb gdn who is been very
patiently helping me through this and
suggesting kindly you should probably read
all the documents on Baker and I'm like okay
fine and I actually am about ready to commit
to it really learning vagrant because I find
it very useful
and I I don't know I I keep thinking if I'm
going to do I can do the same thing with
ansible terraform using I've heard that you
can use terraform using the you know that
you can use their form and then use the the
local provider
they looked at the 1st of October Banner
provider but you know it doesn't it's
delivered provider didn't work very well
when I did it out of the box but you can
definitely do it
what's that if any Paceman call in 5 minutes
yes now I can't I use the enterprise-level
accessory infrastructure know it's
absolutely not it's not it actually should
be you know who uses it the people who need
to provision architecture quickly and test
it on a local system
that's who's using Meghan right now
development shops and architecture shops
that need to deploy
you know Nann simple architectures in order
to do their development and testing
where containers won't cover that container
is coming at 9:10 so that I might get
container will cover that but when it
doesn't cover it like in my case where I
need to provision an extra disc and test
feeling that this so I can create a
community notification that the disease
getting full and type that to my single
which is my immediate demand that's not
something that can be done
you know we've toyed with terraform and
ansible being able to do the same thing so
anyway vagrant is kind of the go to tool for
this for this kind of thing
cell that's that's where we're coming from
back in a day or so I'll dance we're running
kisses to set up her back as good news I
heard it's it's it's old it's like really
really all of the fact that reason I threw
it out the window and it's writing shit
about it as I asked if I could have figured
out needed Baba bhajans right bastard and I
don't know if I think any of that anymore I
because I got it to work and one of the ways
I got it to work was was not swimming
upstream and using the original box driver
instead of Liberty which is a lot slower but
it's got a pretty broad support across and
there's a great recipes for all kinds of
stuff
Universal boxes are pretty standard thing to
do anyway so this is what I did actually
this came from my BG babe put the the school
thing that gives you a static IP we
discovered yesterday after a lot of waste of
time that if you don't do that and you don't
add this
that you're you'll end up with
and if you don't do that you'll end up with
systems that have the same ethernet
have the same address you're like what the
fuc nothing is a long time to figure out but
that's a problem with the image of probably
not like when we don't know but this is the
way to do it and it's actually gives you a
consistent IP number so that I can then do
that I can script the the the Manifest
creation so it was me why are you doing Anna
Faris in vagra doesn't make any fucking
sense and the reason I'm doing it in vagrant
is because I want to simulate creating an
NFS Mount and doing that work a real keep
doing that work in any other ways rather
dangerous in my opinion and how are you
going to test creating an NFS
hey going to do it
you know you going to provision the volume
you got to put a different thing you can do
but you know testing on your Hardware I mean
that's how we used to it so they can is a
good way for testing this setup and
practicing and I think just registration
Baker in his is got a lot of a lot of tools
was that by default that VM only has a net
only network interface
yeah the root cause was that by default the
VM only has not only network interface
and that was the net inside of a gnat and
that's why they all have the same IP
which is weird I mean you think they would
still I don't know why I feel like they
should have at least change the Mac
addresses even if they were all mad and you
know him by that but since they were like
mine. I guess I figured we didn't need to
just give Mom a sandwich it was very weird
to me I did not
can't wait to hit the net yam
yeah you do we did but he and I don't need
to hit the network on this is just bigger
right the whole point of doing this is I I
want stuff to be contained I don't the whole
reason for using a VM for this kind of stuff
instead of Darker it because I want the
volumes of stuff to be contained and safe to
use
I do. I do want it interesting that it
didn't create a drive here
did you notice that did you know that LPG
when I gave it a name last time when I give
it a file it actually made the the file
here and I think I think the new driver the
one that we experimental driver I think it
actually stores the drive someplace else
impregnate your face yes you need to add a
new network private network interface yes
and that's that's what I was missing and I
mean I'm learning begging as we go the hard
way so
so that's what we did we added that
so we needed to add
all right let's do
or are you provision so let's do it by hand
and came back so you ain't had an ex
examples added
I know I like X example that at one point
actually at one point I had that
yeah if you want to addicts example is fine
I I put
I put all that under description but I like
I would like to be able to pull the example
separate from the description
yeah if you want to put a folder question on
that let me know
yeah I mean there's I found another library
that does non Cobra kind of stuff to you if
you're interested
escoger Coco dancer from topic let's do this
so we're going to do
I'm going to split this up and I'm going to
do the steps by hand and then I'm going to
try to automate them
and there's something in my hand is because
I'm trying to solidify my knowledge of i n f
s o what is NFS I don't want to get into it
talked about yesterday NFS is the network
files stored protocol a file system from
file server whatever you call it what is it
actually stand for
Network file system never file server
what's the official title number file system
overview forever it's a protocol that allows
storage over the over the over the network
and it's slow compared to other modern ones
like South Bend stuff like that but still
it's still primarily used for giving any
such as important to know how to do it and
the process of creating a drive on Linux is
another thing this is kind of Linux
infrastructure and write how many how many
raise your hand if you actually Provisions
your own
disc
has anybody ever plugged in their own disc
into the computer or otherwise and set it up
to be a volume on the system to be usable to
be a file here to be able to see CDN to it
and write stuff into it in files or
something. That is like a fundamental task
of Unix system administration and if you're
doing it after using if you're using aren't
you had to do it that way right yeah if
you're so Arch people know how to do this
right because they do it all the time this
is it is very educational so if you want to
go through the old school way of setting up
a Lennox machine like I used to do back in
the 90s we setting up our church requires
you to do all that stuff I hand it isn't
just magically work when you turn it on a FS
are in a mess I don't care about the
comparison between the two I am again I'm a
very practical person and NFS is the thing
to use
now it's either NFL starts with a newer
version right NFS in our case is the the
abstraction to an NES solution is also the
abstraction to gpfs which is another IBM
solution c o n f s tends to be the middle
ground because it's so common even though
it's got problems so you have to do and what
I need to do so I need to go on the system
are you going to control
and it's give me the warning cuz they do
things burn one of my own and even Ellis be
okay let me show you your block devices so
he can see we have sta this is this is SDF
it's as if he has got your ID for sure right
so I used to be
God damn I mean back in the day it was IDE
version either this is a protocol for a disc
attached to the device you know what's crazy
is the standard so sketchy or say that if
you have if you have you know ssds and you
have nvme India me is is his big long ass
thing so it doesn't have a melting point and
there's nothing really there are you going
to sell the swap doesn't have a non-point
right because it's just a vault it's just
it's just a block of ones and zeros in 0 on
a distant place at s file that that is used
by the system however it wants to know what
is melted that means it's got a file system
on top of it it's a week this is the steps
we need to create the partition which we did
already through vagrant we need to mount the
point oh boy
what is this optional vagrant setup for
Microsoft
he's begging for being provisioning however
it is not necessary I want to Biggers
installed
megabox add Fedora why would they say
they're using liver to
else we got
am I right hat Microsoft
they provide baking soda for the really
interesting EVS CO2 vagrant
organization file
well that's actually good as I think of that
that's another you know a good indication
that they going to still use out there it's
not that it might not be commonly is I first
heard about it from a really Kick-Ass
Security administrator on YouTube can't
remember who it was they did not have any
likes or subs or anything but they were
really neither shit and they use vagrant to
simulate kubernetes up and down all the time
they bring up Complex Community environments
like at the drop of a hat using vagran that
we're not many Cube they had they consider
their own storage classes and everything and
so I think this is a real key to Lynn
operators kind of you know to the toolbox so
let's go for it so the next steps are too
the next the next steps are to go into sdb
and to make it into a thing right now is
just a blob of ones and zeros in a volume
that doesn't really matter doesn't have any
music system doesn't know about it there's
no way to contact the seller anything and so
we're going to do we going to see who asks
you to ask me to do a lot of stuff is rout
an extra going to do going to make when you
run a program called fdisk and you have to
point this out the volume that you want to
do SUV or at the are going to partition so
if this goes for partitioning I destroyed so
are the volume and you can see all the
things you can do here we did this yesterday
but I'm going to the fastest time you can
see how much free space do you have it
really doesn't have to be that complicated
so if we do
every free you season all that all that case
we have nine make free right so we're going
to add a new one in his new I think we want
a new primary partition over the whole this
without partitioning
yeah why would you do that though
I've never used it that way though I've
always had a partition like a primary
partition on the disk
I've never I've never seen that in Practical
usage I've always seen this get partitioned
it's a bunch of ice yeah but then all your
references would be the STD right
I mean I see you say let's try it let's try
it again what other reason would you use a
VM for this
images of the hardware I would not want to
fuck around with it right because this is
just a VM I can try all kinds of shit this
is why we're doing this so let's be
dangerous right let's go ahead and run has
been making Fest directly to create a file
format the hard drive make a file system for
ext4 which is the main one and we haven't
been created yet / bass / it's been
make a fast study xt4
NSL / sstb please no
your idea NFL status of the device path I
don't like you guys whenever I can avoid
them
I try to yeah
I know this is going to be really
interesting cuz I've never yeah
I mean it may turn it into a disc
before it was just a part so
I don't know one buggy battle
it actually is a couple of Elmo
it's nice that the order that just changes
for example yeah
yeah the partition so what's up I'm just
going to
mounts
sdv this is so weird and have a number I am
not used to that
not used to that at all yeah it works shit
shit so we don't need to see the partition
ha I mean for the sake of this
I mean for the sake of this I don't we kind
of don't need it
as I said before you can use you can use
Baker in to allocate new discs right
there's no Perdition I don't know it's dry
it's a good thing we're just doing this
Susie something that's not I mean real
sgv if you want my prediction is this guess
but I can see that oxt for Saints Row IV
removed. I command
Prince stb is it sulfa volume
I just Mabel. I'm just going in for huh
there's no free on there
wait what there's nothing free on there
oh that's confusing has super confusing cuz
it says it's there's got free space on there
but it doesn't
because there's no positions written to him
is his trainer is a partition table and I
can't see it
if it's sinful as a digital yeah
yeah that that's super cool II that feels so
wrong to me
I mean I understand I grew up in a time when
you always partition your disc always is
like not an option and everybody you know I
made it home at 7 partition excetera and
then they would export their home directory
animal to survive but
I'm going to put that in my set are you
Sylvia M yeah
you don't have to Partition
U part it has become standard for punishing
now
g p t I think it's more Saturday if this guy
just know I have to ask why would you use
vagrant to make volumes like this so you can
fuck around this stuff and then reverted you
can't do that in a container and you can't
do that with physical stuff easily so
I'd be obvious but you can
used was it at sea
the dog is yelling at my wife is so funny
again this is another thing and I think came
out of the virtualization craze in the
virtualization craze allocating disk space
is just a matter of chopping up you know
some file size someplace so the partitioning
becomes less of an issue because you can
actually Define volumes to be smaller and
use that instead of petitioning and it
simplifies you're used to volumes
I got to put a note about that let's try as
you farted next to shower let's try gparted
so no
I guess I have to write the whole just a I
guess I could I can probably just still use
it even though it's already there and just
blow out the other partition table to sir
oh wait it's not on there by default do you
know where it was it what it is
yeah I departed a graphic gparted is he part
of the graphic one there is a version that's
not graphic
I mean parted gparted is the graphic one
right yeah I don't want to grab it then cuz
I don't have graphics
is it going to eat right is farted
parted oh no we don't want the recipe a bad
bad parted
again if I if I put away I wouldn't lose
anything right yeah we don't want to no one
yeah sub welcome
pardon help was the commands holy shit I
don't know this cuz I've never used it
did you print a list of your commands hey
how's it going
we talked about lab changes recently and
about formatting at some point
yeah that made me think I might talk about
his I moved all of the references from my
labs out so that the lab is just a statement
of work like this is if something needs to
be done and I started putting everything
into a work directory that's my solution for
that particular thing parted yeah I'm I'm
not so far I'm not a fan of it make label
and make part name number for Prince quiet
select device like
Atlee best disc fdisk is kind of all over
the place just total
yeah I don't know I don't know if I would
use I would probably accept disc
is it a great yeah I'm a fan of ignorant
again any bigger look I'm also going to
teach Ruby
so yeah I'm a bunch of realization just hit
me that are pretty strong
yeah it's and how is he going to make a
machine out of mine you do a terraform
I got to do with ansible as much as I hate
it
Packers doesn't make her some machine Packer
is like I finished machine right
if so
yeah I'm I'm the biggest pain point was live
birds and and I I love the bird it's very
fast and all but I bet I'm going back to
Virtual devices original box original box
and everything has worked
everything just totally works
oh God I think I can use logic
I'm going to stick with fdisk on this we all
set to go to automated
so how do we do that actually know this can
be automated on myself we don't even need
the other stuff
yeah in one week a boy engineering design
engineering design designing Helm charts to
fix the claimants allege No Cap no idea I
haven't taken it I haven't take a big
Blaster this people here at people in the
community can probably tell you in the crazy
thing is is it nobody here actually has
their search a clean people that are on the
cloud 8 of bored
and so they have art and tell me what's on
the test I'm not a fan of him but I
understand
do you understand that Helm charts are
actually
you know what's cool about this is that we
can just run this and we don't have to do
you know what I'm glad you did that because
how would you how would you describe to
scrap the next strip the creation of it can
you connect to speed run from command line
I've never done it
right now I'm making an FS mount for a
vagrant setup virtual machines
yeah
all right I don't know what to do here I'm
trying to decide
I don't like parted oh parted he could run
to the command line
well it's clearly included so that would
probably be the way to scripted right
I'm going to look this up because it for the
sake of learning
if I wanted to partition how did your new
command line create
create a partition I'm not command line
and a greater delete partitions using
command prompt imparted
cmdr command prompt this part this is
Windows this is Windows
now that's when those who don't want that
prison hard riding my life prompt
you seem to think I just have to put Linux
on there I guess so
attic reproductions a Linux any part of disc
if I'm going to add this document
why because I want to add to my notes
just give me a chart
I like that you're great I didn't hate it
when I first started using it but boy if I
come to hate it
I just have to know what though is only
added to the 2022 so please come back and
report on what's on their own without giving
away something to get you in trouble because
I have to take it and I'm getting ready to
do ramp up my learning on how to do it when
it was on the test everything is a
preparation for area so we're going to be
going to be doing it every Saturday we're
going to be doing three days after patient's
development stuff
so yeah that's definitely coming
alright so he's freezing every display the
harder I like she's with struct
she can party at Shell Savers near me
yeah
okay so you're at your impression she can't
order that is it is more beginner-friendly c
k that's that's what I've heard that twice
now
so I don't know but that's it's something
want to do a suggestion predictions
all this stuff has me doing it like not
interactively mounted
yeah you could you make it past dashti
that's another better better command like
your stream ID like your stream ID
I said I could work did you type a message
or did you ever sit in your video
if your video you have to delete the whole
thing what you can do as you can when the
video editor Angeles rates go into the video
editor and create a highlight and then
highlight the entire video except for that
part and then save that is a highlight and
delete the bod
that way you can clip it out you can shop it
out represent
yeah I've had to do that too usually these
days I'll just delete the bod
alright so
I don't want to do that primary wanted it
back over here
I'm kind of distracted Lucy here so
best have to file is he can pass a script
file to have disk via. She'll really
I haven't done this stuff I just lose the
always Interactive
admission to the Saint Francis Hospital or
is that that I
and I'm guessing it's a tie do you see cell
receptors wife
high pressure versus Isis Lee blah
whoa yeah
it's just a make it past it's not doing the
partitioning
oh my God
I don't know if I can accept this solution
here this is no a bunch of echo statements
I know it's got to be something better than
that
no
it is that the only thing that be okay and
that would make me use part in just that
that is not not cool
I would not do that let me sit re-centered
input and that's so dangerous if they change
the commands and anyway
yeah
hey I just don't I think that would be
enough to make me his pardon
so let's do another search
I can make mac and light Lennox farted
bad yellow I think you're right it's part of
this is relatively new I never learned it so
we just read this one I didn't have any
automation using part of command this
message in the scraper Edition
I mean we already did this one
I'm sure is it something that I just don't
know the committee's
he's right it's make part o that supported
command
oh you have it above okay here we go
all right I got to make I can make something
for that
use of parted for creating
Visions from Eli
a boy hey how's it going nice post
yeah I would not do stbf yeah run it
yes but if they go warning here
2048 sectors 4%
only if you could do without sectors
you can tell me our positions with some
great with purchasing fools like you being
other yes yeah I wouldn't be doing that
though in this case so yeah
I mean and that's pretty much what beautiful
means but it depends on what system your own
butt
all right that's a nice tool drip tip to
have I do kind of want to try it
they're trying to remember s discs
ssf2 spin around a while
this planet might just be able to bring a
block of ice
what would you use would use parted
if you can take it if you would use pardon
or would you use something else
what one would you prefer
didn't realize that the starting over dishes
I accept this to ya lvm
yeah but that's that's usually for more
significant volume set up straight I would
think
all right sfjazz going to start it in two
partitions to walk devices
are going away is not dispensing I start off
sets at all
I see
last time I did I script using.
Yeah
is parted s f disc
and how would you do the same thing with
this up desk
the ssf is allows or the same
then what yeah yam
yeah I'm trying to figure out how we would
do the same thing
Jason holyshit then partition 7 Jason and
Jasonand Jason for men
got I got to see that I have to see that in
use
I just got news oh oh
there's no except disc so there you go that
uses the curses Library
I'm going to I'm going to revise my
statement here
why did I miss that oh well I got it wrong
thank you for catching that
thank you for catching that I miss that you
guys love watching me make those kind of
mistakes I know
because I don't read well as long as I'm
entertaining you with my stupidity
as if disc Dev sdb
to remember your latest a right then stb
any credit you do 7 I think it's all command
line stuff shit
I like it that
I don't want now I want to know what the
option is
I want it now I have to figure out how to do
it how do we do this exact same thing in it
would be
we probably have to cat into it pipe
something anyway I'm guessing
her create a table yeah I guess is that's
true too
I can try to get a table and it doesn't it
know it doesn't
look at that that is kind of cool I mean
that is kind of cool
you know I like about that is that you can
write up applications that went
yes
yeah I know how you would Adam and but that
would be I would be a thing
that's if you prefer at this afternoon
I can replace it with his help I think it'll
work where to find out
find
there we go
Bacchus or partition tables that's
interesting I hadn't even thought of that
party
make sure your primary make sure you have
missed us
yeah I kind of like that I kind of like it
yeah yeah so
then you can just dump it with us fdisk at
you later and used them to create a petition
again
stack Overflow example yeah yes Krypton
version of Estes it's all part of you till
the next
cuz I got to see Sylvia was the same person
table single partition
you could put this in our notes inara
coloring notes
God knows I ain't over do it with no taking
but
I mean why not right if we're going to go
through the research might as well start
someplace
115 sizer
oh yeah of course if you're changing the
size not going to resize your stuff for you
but if you see it as soon as you can dump
the petition layout
r s t s s e y s interesting
you're not using a GPD with this disc it is
not as a combination
sister has been an assistant for CPT include
G disc and S U disc or Char. Just have to
skin Essentials
seems like there's a little bit of a
competition between them I said just use
descriptive version of fdisk
as part of your Tales Lennox version table
the single Jason Takes a whole District
rating with
as you at the funeral where can I purchase
do it's been below
s f disc hip hop point of my Lenovo equals
blah
interested if I can apply it with sgx
with Sudoku oh you can type the whole thing
shut
we happen to be the actual partition table
that's that's kind of interesting but you
can just admit it by saying she's a lot
types of line
start size type of animal
and you can set bootable so I don't know
what I'm saying here and B are supported
yep I had a feeling you know that it's not
as straightforward
you know in part it seems like it has
a command that you can use it like gives you
what you want I feel like you have to create
a file for us up disk and you afford it to
it which is totally fine too it's just a
different thing right
I just sent you two I haven't known about it
I'm just discovering it was just when I'm
spending too much time on it
it is such a secondary sector 15 in cat
a some a different you know what I'm going
to say something I should probably take the
time to set up an Arch Linux distro from
scratch I should probably do that this isn't
a learning exercise because
so many of the tools that I grew up with are
irrelevant now like at disc
and so it should work yeah it is just one
line so yeah
yet for this particular one right sidestep 7
bootable
I mean to send taxes a little hairier
Tempo formats a genericthe generic header
lines
that referral Bridges oh God I'm not doing
this that's stupid
list all expect running expect script to
make a partition you fucking kidding me okay
delete hacker method of doing for expecting
a four digits no fuck know that's crazy is
really crazy oh my God this is so this is a
perfect example of Stock Exchange look at
this is the most popular answer and it's a
disaster
oh my God it's so bad and it's the most
upvoted one
oh my God they give you for that
I thought that was a good idea I mean even
the shell script is kind of bad oh God
it's is provided a sense of enjoyment for me
today and made me laugh
yeah
what's the question that was above the
answer was was was with the layout which one
was it was somebody right
yeah is it kind of too
it I want it I want to do something here I
want to
is assef
bunting I was afraid of that I was reading
that
trip to do
2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2
set link s f disc
all right yes yes please all right and then
you get
I got those notes
thank you for that this is like I'm going to
go back to something again I take an
unusually large amount of notes because it
helps me remember
it helps me remember stuff that are and then
I can go back and find it more easily than
just a bunch of random bookmarks
how many vaccines go back to your bookmarks
and search for things I don't
so let's do this let's see I mean I I've
satisfied my my urge to partition that I
don't even need to as LBG has told us we can
just use the makeup s option And the fact I
want to use a better format for this we
actually should probably use make a fuss
type t e x t 4 that's the more supportive
way to do this
okay just say format
lion would make it fast no partition needed
and I appreciate you bringing that to my
attention I would never have thought of that
by default
I would never have thought of that by
default
okay
so are we are we are at this great whatever
raise volume two points anything with makeup
best
remind me just because he's a protector yeah
people keep saying that no parts
or boot sector needed
thanks for that Frank that's a good note
let's make sure that's in her notes
if we do I mean that's most beginners are
not going to know that they don't know what
it what sector is
yeah it it was kind of freaked me the fuck
out doing you know Dennis EB
and I've gotten so paranoid about doing
Tennessee letter anything over the years
because that's the parent disc to the
partition
yeah I mean it's like it's pretty common to
do different commands to the partition with
a number at the end and when is it like
major major faux pas as you might make his
assistant men is forgetting the number at
the end
because what happens right so let's say
let's say you have a hard drive and it's got
five partitions on edge and you want to
format one of the specific partitions you
want to reformat or you want to clear it up
for swap space you want to release it
whatever right so he went to resize it so
you do whatever the command is and you point
it at the SD be 1 or 2 or 10 or 3 and I've
done it that's why I'm so paranoid about it
that that's why I'm so paranoid about it and
encouraging
if that guy just talked myself into
partitioning anyway because if a beginner
sees this and then they they think that they
don't need to indicate the partition the
chances of actually doing this command on a
volume that has not been partitioned even if
it only has a single partition is very low
and I would rather not encourage people to
drop the numbers from the end as a present
at our practice because they all as soon as
you do that you are going to fuck yourself
over and everybody knows we'll have it so so
as cool as it is that you can do that
I think it's kind of going against the grain
so maybe it's more acceptable in the world
of virtualization where volumes as I said or
you know could be done
I'm going to actually make a comment on this
on this this this thing that I said
because I'm really really glad that I'll
meet you showed us about that trick but
yeah but should I you drop
drop partitioning
34 Frederick Street
one of the only ways one of the many ways a
beginner like me once upon a time
I can destroy a perfectly good disc
is to leave off the number of the partition
Deb S TV
instead of death stb-1
for this reason I feel
I ain't taking the unnecessary step of
creating a single partition for the entire
Dr will seem more normal two admins old and
young
I'm not sure
I want to encourage people to ever stop
paying attention to the numbers
of the partitions just for the sake just for
the safety net
it provides
before work a tension is absolutely of
course using lsblk is definite
play the way to go to avoid all of this
confusion but having a partition table
I might still avoid some mishaps
why not as using icat and logic
what we talked about code there's no code
here
this this is Mark down mister cat hate Kenny
logic this is what you need to do
yeah but you didn't finish this other stuff
so you should probably go do the Boost
there's a there's 45 minutes 45 hours of or
more of a video booths there that will catch
you up to everything we're doing here.
Everything good
is it for the boot sector for bring some
text Pac-Man in 512 flight said so cool
super cool so
has been for going to do this
I feel like I feel I feel better writing
that
that's all that matters I do a Wonder though
but let's try let's try automating it this
is all marked down yet just coming work work
town
a partition cell produces a different thing
predictions are just talking about how to
how to chop up your disk drives and create
different partitions
which is part of infrastructure engineering
oh I got this pretty cool
all right let's do
I am trying to redo this actually
I want to kill that petition and and mount
I whoops and I'm going to actually delete it
or or put something else on it
let's try our petition command that we were
playing with us try lbg's departed command
let's try that was Joey so animal primary
SUV make part primary okay we want
all 10 MB so do we actually have to indicate
how much of it
I could get it to hundred percent can't we a
strike
is it good thing I would not test on
anything but a VM but we're on a VMware
virtual volumes or fine
oh that's not good
make label MS-DOS drop this
and I'll talk Infirmary houses in New York
City to ha
this NFL season 5 fc2
I'm part 1 start
make level made the partition table
62 okay do these are commands that it sends
to him I see
04 or is it Linux Linux right
and damn it how do I find out what take as
it is the xt4
you just label I just label type what's in
Cambodia
I don't know I'm going to go do it
interactively and then I'll figure out the
command now that I understand that they're
just commands
so
has a basement okay I'll see you make label
you just label time
how do we list all the labels I know how to
do this would have just got to know how to
do it here
and I'll token I know I need to read about
it I haven't read anything about it
help I think I'm already stuck in one
yeah I can't
sales are expected to sell out game help
I never responded ever in my life so make
level
can you just go Fishin I will type as one of
Atari i x PSG sun or Lube
if I can get Amy
we can do labor if imma do Looper gptm
thinking why would it be a mustache
no it isn't us it is essentially is because
I remember that this could doing that
a clamble and estas Knox
warning system disabled on us to be able to
destroy all day on this will be lost you
want to continue yes
I see this doesn't wanted a time this
doesn't like and I'll give you options be
outside so next we need to do
thenthen pardon dash s
does it read the lines in without the quotes
shit that is awesome
that is awesome I would not have guessed
that make part
make Park Primary ext4
what are 2048 that's the sector's right lb *
4 can we do can we have a gig
I wonder if we can do gig
I mean that's going to make a specific
position size I want to use that have used
to hold the whole disk I wonder how that is
I don't know
110 G it doesn't probably do that anyway the
sector's probably right
I mean it's money manager that this
yesterday I can say hey how big is that use
the whole thing
oh that's the start I do that's the
beginning sector location how would you even
figure that out
it had to like Melissa petition people
already
is starsector in sector
you bet how did you know to skip over is
that the nbar size 2048 sectors
what where is the 24th coming from Ice Cream
all the time
I go on and off all the time it's going to
be all right as soon as 24 days pretty
standard
and if you can't do it that has a 512 MB
or fights whatever it is what what's the
standard and BR size I can't remember
the basic it's a bad idea to write directly
to the beginning of this evidence to the
volume. Right because it's the partition
table itself gets written there
I'm wondering if part of that actually let
you write over the partition table to be in
and that would be really bad news right
what are the main desk
I'm just wondering how I would know that
it's probably a standard number and we can
just use that kind of all the time
iHeartRadio is greater than p
so 2048 sectors I think it's pretty much
basic right as it started and then we went
to 10% so
waiting about fair play name the sounds of
music
how are you
let's see how so we need to do
Michigan say create great the devil on
version
it's done defeating a man
well that's nice that has some of the
commands right it's probably that nothing is
going to write a ride I'll be a Flags
started 1049 KB
how's it going
isn't really a language this is just a bunch
of stuff
yeah we're using 1X and we're doing part of
partitioning and bunches
Michelle was the best answer I can give you
a shelf we're just we're doing right now
we're doing a little bit of Ruby a little
bit of Ash
little bit of some domain specific languages
for these tools like party so let's see here
it said he write it I bet it does at my exit
Emmett how do I exit
I've never she's part is Donna
the language of English is it cute
be okay they want me to update I-77 my own
I don't fucking want to fuck with a Vista
please tell me I don't have to do that
oh my God I'm going to have to
on this is doesn't mean it but this will
happen when you do melting and stuff yeah
that's that's next that's after me Mountain
stuff
there you go that's what you wanted so they
can most definitely be scripted
can only capture that that specific
I think and I want to write about the okay
I'm going to write about this
block storage device volume
Rob volume
the commands are surrounded by
quotes but don't necessarily have to be
lgbtq what do you use a hard disk greater
than 4 terabytes
yes I kind of want to play with that
if I could be a time after you partition a
USB stick yeah
at suck
and this toss creates the Shannon table
C make part
creates the mission
as a race a primary partition
which can hold other partitions if you want
later
that begins starts at
and Phyl's of the disk volume
fraction operations repeat it has
interesting
I did not know that I'm learning a lot about
Furnishing again
and it just feels SS which spent more come.
It was you saying Okay so
I was going to find the lab on this I'm
willing to I'm willing to
yes all right so notes on that or updated
we have a desk frame
you can actually put all the commands on the
same line just remove the thing on your dog
what is a semicolon screwing us up
oh what's
and now it's soaking house that invalid
token yeah
yes oh we're going to put an F in here to
force it right
if we need to do
watching crime shows out besides with the
Davion default yep
yeah but I mean yeah I use it they made a
false ID IP Lux encryption all that stuff I
default with the installers at setting up
your own discs is a very unique thing but
it's something I need to do for the NFS oh
so you know I'm doing a testing is kind of a
lost art of to that you know it's not
something people do it's it's kind of taken
care of for you
are you trying to show me oh boy
that looks like it did yeah
all in 1 hour to get a line right yeah but
but I we learned a ton in the process right
I mean I know about part it I know that I
can be able to that's a pretty pretty
a pretty simple and intuitive lying to set
up a volume petition and I really appreciate
that we figured this out the script volume
partitioning is fucking amazing I'm really
glad I learned it I know where to go back
for it now I'm not going to go deep dive
into partitioning just right now but I know
where the information is and what to look
for and as an operations person as you guys
are well know that's half the battle half
the battle is knowing that parted in l s b k
in on those kinds of things even exist right
Mexican run this when they came out here
no I don't want to do that I don't have it I
don't have to be here nevermind I give up
god dammit
there
Nash s
now we need that it doesn't matter Glee
alright so yeah I think it's at the file
system after system
and I just got here facing yes yes I'm stack
exchange oh God yes I am like rooting out
the shit that doesn't work you know
after primary
does any car has to be careful
oh wait wait wait yes Maniac C4
yep when are you sure
that even work
it's optional what I see
that's what that that's optional was
definitely capture that
yeah
medicine wait a second when you do did that
the dent do it implied make of this
it did right shit it didn't quite make a
mess
I think I do we still have to do with your
weight loss check dad
I mean the only reason you would put that
there it was to say hey this is the type of
file system that is intended
but still yeah has to be formatted with
without that could really throw a beginner
they can really throw him again we got to
make sure you cover that it's like hey I put
a text before I went in to make it ext4
visiting form after this can write you need
to make an epicenter I just just make the
volume but it says hey you know
is great that is a size intended
alright so
alright so yeah
is makes a mortician it doesn't fill ya in
Everwood right I just I think it's important
we pointed out the beginners because when
they get what's your excuse for I said
that's a file system in a tank but I thought
this was just
this was just partitioning it didn't have
any file system stuff inside yeah that's
right it's just an informational field of
the partition table
nothing stopping you from putting an
informational fill the partition table
Linens and in formatting with a completely
new Partition so
you know I beginner needs to hear then or me
after 20 years Cersei
I want to say it's been 20 know that's not
true
that's not true because I was doing a bunch
of USB partitioning and making disk using
actually Mac command line for adjusting tool
that's the last time I was messing with
projections by 2014 is e l s
I sent a response Redemption tag I thought
about that I don't know that's interesting I
don't know
it doesn't build out their Festival a reason
to be treated as a male
I am a little bit interested to get into why
that we're only starting the volume on 2048
sector which is like you know 10:24 or so
I know that we're just giving space for
producing Tales of some of the beginning or
volume information the beginning the
partition table itself is getting written to
the beginning of the desk and I think
there's a standard size there and I I don't
know I think it probably depends on the
petition type as well
or did they all just comply with the
standard size so that starting number the
starting number 24 dates actors
is that standard across all partitions are
all partitioning you know architectures
I think it is I think it is because I've
seen it everywhere every time you ever going
to use that this or something like that it
says where am I going to start and then it
automatically starts you at that spot
because it's already written vertically or
whatever to the beginning of the volume
nnn the stuff is ready to begin the volume
of thing is done by the provisioner
I don't know that though
so I'm super interested to know about that
like what's going on at the very very
beginning of the disc
High b key
Artisan have boxes by 12 for k b Finney on
her again yep
yes b o b
January B yes
is like a human size probably too much over
yet I understand why we have to skip that
passed 2048 sectors and I'm almost positive
that it's a partition table but I don't know
them
self with a box eyes
yes
and I think the first block or two is is
like if you want it but it wouldn't want to
know is that leave room for an MPR few want
one
like if you were to make it bootable in
front of me are on there later this is that
does that save enough space for that to be
at a later you have to go full report isshin
I know that this isn't it might be I do feel
like it's
it's like hey we're not going to touch the
beginning of the discus with all kinds of
shit going on the beginning
Carowinds just read GTA software engineering
a kingslayer
yeah we do bunch of shit here welcome can
see you
you got any answer for us already oh God
oh God
because you'll just a additional utilities
that's the only substance is used to sleep
that use the same to me didn't try climate
using entire fake this geometry that you see
reopened and your do this has been or is
partitioned man you are utility Alliance one
megabyte boundaries instead
I see yeah my you found it right away
what is Medusa's story 24 days of 63 there
it is right there on 2nd Street
restaurant Stock Exchange you found it so
fast
I'm going to write a thing about that though
10% I know I was just going to say
that's why I was like I'm already down to 9%
of my MB of disk right
by making a partition table
if I had made it a volume I would have got
all 10 GB right yeah
I see you're saying Physicians are bloat
yeah they are
so that's interesting
I like what you're saying there that's
actually part of that other idea that we
were talking about I want to capture that so
on the other hand rotisserie chickens
cause bloat
because of old conventions about
about when the partition about where the
position can be in
obviously in a terabyte
Discworld such things are not that big of a
concern
but if for any reason you are constrained on
disk space you might want to drop
partitions all together and just
format the volume directly
yeah podesta flag
did you do
bring your own practice Yeah
we've been talked about that a lot that's
pretty common kingslayer it's pretty common
topic colleges teach you Theory and you
don't have any practical stuff if you need
to learn practical stuff like how to get a
job and you can read he's in the next like
that you got to supplement your learning
somehow and one of those ways to boost but
mostly it's just practicing what should
making your own stuff
yeah it you probably most people prefer
practical learning cuz it's the natural way
to learn learning theory from a book and
read about it is not it's not natural sew-in
people prefer to experiment try things out
and then come back and read about stuff to
fill the gaps as comprehensive learning most
people that's the natural and do things cuz
that's how we learned as a kid that's how
nature does learning and colleges don't do
that they don't let me know if that based on
Theory cuz I can't keep up with the
Practical applications of that theory
because it changes too quickly so they still
your money and
steal your money and teach you Theory and
leave you without the ability to pay the
money back cuz you don't have the fucking
job
so I don't know what to tell you except for
make sure you supplement whatever you're
doing in college with a bunch of practical
learning that you do on your own and learn
how to figure out how to manage your
learning on your own because if you don't
learn that fucking any job because all jobs
require you to learn practical skills on the
job all the time and if you don't learn that
you'll fail so make sure you learn it and
the best way to learn is is jump in and do
it you already know how to do it by the way
it's built into you pretty much I talk about
this on the first the first the second day
of the Boost Labs yeah I just have a saying
learning happens in the lab not the lecture
hall
I'm sad again learning happens in the lab
not the lecture hall what I'm doing right
now is crazy good for my learning because
I'm experimenting I'm testing I'm
collaborating with other people while we do
it just like serious fucking learning
happening right now
if I were to read a book about this about
how to set up an offense Alyssa if I would
not get nearly as much practical inside from
all the other people that have done it
running is also collaborative
this bunch of shit that's just totally wrong
it's not competitive learning its
collaborative it's not competitive
you said you sent people against each other
in a college classroom stick on a fucking
bill curve cost of the competition so they
don't ever fucking help each other unless
they go out of their way to do like you know
coating do you like things but it sets up
this antagonistic situation between the
teacher and the student in between the
student in this student is totally fucked up
it's totally totally fucked up and you end
of the world thinking that that's how you
should go about learning to do you send your
cubicle and you have great knowledge you
don't ever share with anybody else so you
don't ask somebody real somebody else and
they beat you down because they're competing
against you for the job to get a raise every
thing and it and there's a scarcity
mentality it's all totally totally freaked
out
throw that off if you want to learning
community like ours or another one learn how
to learn on your own and just flip the fuck
off every other educational institution that
is trying to steal your money
it's true it's you don't you think it's not
your raise your hand if you have run into a
technocrat in it in the it profession who
doesn't share shit because they're afraid
you're going to get a job we're going to do
better than them
I've met so many of these people it's
obscene and you know it's just downright
wrong as this is scarcity mentality if you
succeed that means I'm not going to succeed
totally fucked up
all right I'm going to go away now let me
get myself talking about I get mad
that's enough for that when my life right so
let's go get some notes Here the idea of you
know I know
so kingslayer the first of all takes take
heart and knowing that you do not need to be
afraid you don't need to be afraid the whole
system would have you be full of fear fear
of trying to learn fear of getting the wrong
grade fear of being in the wrong major for
going to run school if they are learning the
wrong thing they want you to do that because
they have control over you
so drop the fear I know I have had to fight
against the fear to myself I was terrified
when I got hired for this job I didn't know
anything about Community Center stardew
kubernetes if you only knew I could learn it
and you know why they hired me
I have to keep reminding myself of this they
hired me because I had my CV was Chuck full
of proof
that I have taught myself and learn how to
learn that's why they hired me that's why
they hired me I told him point-blank and
interview is a very cushy job and I told him
point-blank an interview I have zero Docker
kubernetes experience and the position was a
doctor in kubernetes admin
and it's a don't worry you'll learn it don't
worry you'll learn it a mic
they had seen my vastu yet they had they had
seen my videos and I had had they had had
somebody from the videos a friend of mine
now
go to them and say you would be a fool if
you didn't hide those exact words to be a
fool if you didn't hire this guy and that's
how you get a job you get a job by creating
trust with other people are going to
recommend you because it bypasses HR and all
that shit and number two I don't care if
it's downdraft or not if they're going to
hire me for my
if you're going to hire me for my personal
rants on Twitch, I don't want to work for
them
I don't want to work and defense against
standards stuff by and seeing that there are
at least two independent limitation of The
Sinner interesting
standard something that's super interesting
you run into technocrats and different
contacts people to try to land their
company's Solutions standard while all the
other Solutions while they need a couple
years to migrate and keeping on some of the
bigger companies to write so I really liked
what they taught
I have a fucking Russian major you think my
Russian major got me my job know I'm a
liberal arts major for one of the most
technical positions you could ever get hired
for
education system has such a big fuss about
cheating oh got ya memorization for this is
these are the standard complaint points from
Paula Ferry end and can Robinson never said
they want to do that's because that's where
they have all the power if you're just a
memorization machine they have all the power
and they can charge you money to certify
yeah you can erase everything nope you can't
every man for themselves ever going to find
a messenger again
because that's the system that they want you
know
effectively gate keep you out of your
control points and that's what we're finding
is right at right so that's a great rant
binary if you can't rent here look I just
want you to know something
this cement okay this community I'm trying
really hard to make it a safe space am I
going to ban you and time you out and get on
your case if you you know if I feel attacked
probably am I going to cool off I'm going to
make tons of mistakes along the way but
overall I want you to know this community is
a safe space for you to learn now we are
going to push you we're not this is some
mamby pamby like snowflake shit if you fuck
up by doing something that you could have
answered in two seconds on your own we're
going to get your shit about it but it's
good for you it's good for you when I kind
of I mean if we're meeting with you it's
because we love you and I know that sounds
horrible to say but it's true because if you
go into some if you if you wander into some
random C programming IRC Channel and you say
hey can I ask a question here and you say
something like that the fucking rip you a
new one is it a good thing that they do that
no but that's the reality of the situation
so it's like being in the military right it
really is and and it was like two people
the military had a guy it was my senior
manager he tweeted we call him Sarge it was
a kind of sweetest guys you never know his
mouth on that guy he would yell at us and
you would say shit that wasn't me he was he
was honest I'm not saying it was good I must
say it was uplifting but that was it that
was the nature of the Beast and in you had
to get used to it and I have met very
significant philosophical odds with a lot of
other streamers over this particular
specific point they say don't follow mentor
to teach you to be an asshole and I'm like
I'm not teaching you to be an asshole I'm
teaching you to do your own research I'm
pushing back when you say you know what time
is it or things like that and you know and
I'm going to give a shit about it and I'm
going to it when you choose to repeat some
people show out there about how awesome and
such is then I'm going to ask I'm going to
challenge you to justify what you said just
like I would expect you to do for me
and sometimes sometimes I will jokingly call
people that eats in morons and stuff like
that which is something I'm trying not to do
anymore I don't actually mean you're a moron
usually it's a joke usually
it is kind of it is kind of tough love and
you know and I just let you know I'm doing a
little thing here because because the
consensus in software and Tech about me is
that I'm an evil demon it should be avoided
and and I you know I'm I resent that I
resent that I really do because it's like
I'm literally here to try to help you get
this job and no
are contacts this matter is it's the same
criticism of like when is 4 V who cut who
says people don't understand how that they
can feed themselves they should have been
retroactively aboard it and he said shit
like that in writing forever in these groups
know I don't think that's okay it was
hyperbole for sure he didn't really mean it
but even I think that the days of that kind
of hyperbole are gone but the point I'm
trying to make is that
you know when you say someone tell people
come to the city to come to you and they say
tell me what to do tell me where to go you
know why because they've been so bludgeoned
by the
by the system beginning with their parents
according to Paula ferry that they don't
dare to go experiment they're too afraid to
go experiment are too afraid to learn don't
be afraid to learn don't be get over that
shit that they want you to be in a state of
fear all the time the reason and if you're
going to if we're going to rise up against
the powers that control all this shit we got
a state return the first thing we got to
start with taking control of our own
learning and helping others and building a
community about labor union I'm talking
about a community that help each other out
it isn't fighting against the scarcity
mentality is like if you succeed i-60 and we
help each other
and it's not competitive it's not I'm better
than you I am the talking head who's better
than you I am the streamer who's better than
you bow down to me for I am the streamer you
know we don't want that shit
yeah there's enough for everybody so okay
you know so then yeah I agree
enter Dennis the Dennis and I are like
lockstep on that kind of topic we told her
and then you get it running fuck you money
and then you do whatever right
yeah and tell me when I disagree all the
time
but it's a soft disagreement I mean
sometimes it depends I mean if you tell me
I'm a shit programmer I'm going to attack
you or time you out
because it's it might be true I didn't want
to hear it no
so you're wrong you suck what are you going
to tell me why I didn't know to beat me up
and not tell me why
that's a cool cell
and bad for her because I don't think I I
don't I typically don't say you're bad for
me I don't believe I've ever been attacked
for that I've said that certain code was
shit
and if somebody happened to it written that
you would then then yeah I guess it was
implied right
that is your programmer right absolutely
yeah I know that's that's a real that's it
that's a tiny that's a hard part I'm like oh
my God this code is so fucking ugly
and then you proceed to tell them why it's
ugly right
that's my best friend wishing you talking
about Google allow Google for exam
remember zacian doesn't help yeah
education is really behind oh my God yeah so
far behind Frank it really is
yeah yeah my car is terrible to look people
if people think they look if I look at your
phone I see this code is absolute shit
and I look at my own coding like oh my God
this code of shit I'm saying the code is
shit I'm not saying your shit
if you were look at my partitioning skills
right now they oh my God this guy's skills
are shit and Frank has said so
perform when it comes to cutting see oh my
God this Casey Cody Stills or shit they are
shit
you know it's a southern thing I think we
need to start owning our
are what I want to say here are our
weaknesses I think it's okay to be
vulnerable I think you should own your way
cuz it's hard it's hard man I've I'm fired
back pretty heavily on people when they
attacked me really hard it's easy to say
what I just said I don't do it
Arrow TV show will be worse than when I
rotation. Echo strand absolutely
yeah it's a real agree but just don't tell
me that you're going to put if you're going
to put like five likes and pipelines in
there well yeah why are you doing that it's
in the script you could have done it with a
brace mention oh
how do I get I want to hear you if it's what
you do you just copy and paste after we come
in like yeah yeah I can see how I probably
would have done that too that's the way to
go about it but I don't do that sometimes I
just jump right to this go to shit and I
don't do it
don't worry my first cousin did see we're
just all helping each other and we have to
be able to to own that right I think we want
to go to own that
not knowing not knowing you look self
assessing annoying what your weaknesses in
your strengths are it's like an essential
skill in anything in life if you cannot
self-assess rationally and sometimes that
means putting people in your space that are
going to give it to you straight
and you need to be able to take that if
you're not that person then you're just
that person and you're just a trump is a
person like Trump have with that you
surround yourself with people who just
validate what you think about yourself and
that is dangerous oh my God that's dangerous
you want to get people in your circle that
are going to challenge you and then
sometimes in in chest they're going to call
you a moron that's a moronic idea what you
said sale and then we proceeded to explain
why they said that and I got you a fact yeah
setting up to Dunning Kruger is in Boston
right
imposter syndrome it's like thinking you
don't know anything then you figure is not
knowing you don't know
yeah super dangerous to all right so so so
so yeah
cuz you got who you going to see me go all
going to go in a kid sheets to contact his
parents at 60
it depends on how you define cheating you
know
anyway LS be okay
let's put that let's put that partitioning
code finally into our scripture
we need to check out the hostname equals a
thing
If
ice name
then it go yes
did you do did you by the way I can write on
the command line and cut and paste it into
my code and I don't have to order thinking
it's like less cognitive overhead
that is why I'm a big bash man is only one
scripting language to know
all right so if it's control then let's do
as a politician Shelly
I'm going to do Sea-Doo
hearted dash s a c b
ever sent and we could have done ext3 or
finally like that
control yep I think we did it
having to make a mount point hey kingslayer
welcome thank you for the sub
when to do this make make 3 / s
and then we're going to make a file system
on there
let's do that make fsst 64's
SUV 1
done the dishes are done dude
so I'm copying out the commands of doing it
by hand and then I'm coming about it to my
provisioning script so that they get done
automatically when I anytime I bring up this
vagrant collection of the machines that's
what we're doing
and so now what now we've got that now we
need to melt the point so make directory / s
okay and then we need to mounted and we
probably need to add it to
FS tab
I don't know if we need to do because I'm
just going to be taking it down later if we
could probably just do the mountain by hand
what do you think should be added to the fs
tap it doesn't and that it doesn't have his
tablet at fault I don't think right it's
been a while since I've done Mount so I know
that we're just going to do the mountain
directly so let's just do Mount Deb STP 12s
and now a CD into /
CD into / s we have
I'm sitting in / s we should have a
lost-and-found is a dead giveaway and now we
have now it shows up as a partition / SSDI
up until that point it would not show up in
DF output because it do you have only shows
file system usage and if it's not a file
system doesn't show up I do I have to use
lsblk which shows you all the block devices
and now you see it's mounted and slashes so
that's that
I know we need to export if so I suggested
the local area network for NFS and this is
some stuff that I don't do I've never done
it until yesterday and they were actually
export in if I smell before I've used them
I've consumed them a lot but I haven't done
a lot of that I'm kind of want to set up a
sound of Mount also
that be cool
because I'm at summer song by uses smps or
something and that's that if you have a
Windows Network and you do a song about it
will show up on the network
something else are awesome yeah if you put a
salmon out in there like why aren't you VIP
did you get rotated out
uh oh
some of those are awesome because everything
can see it on your network
everything can see it on your network so
yeah
Master like openmediavault does it come with
it
I might can't give you a key did not know
this did not know this hi hun
sweetheart I need to see my fire it's been
on all night I know it's fun huh
alright so let's finish the setup as seen on
take a break and go do something else
although I said been very useful
did you want the shirt back today iron it
for you you can keep it it doesn't fit me
better on you anyway it looks better on you
my yeah it is
that's the only piece of yeah I think that's
the only piece of clothing that I have left
over from my previous Wedding Marriage thing
which was God damn 15 years ago
that sure is old that's like a
fifteen-year-old shirt the only other
clothes I know that come from that is my
boots
and my boots take back to my college days
how are you
you're doing good
finishing up here now let's get this and if
this thing cuz I want to take a break and go
hang out with my wife for a bit
I donate it
an OLED TV no it's just a basic TV
I just have like a like an old school in
0-60 in from the school
it's really big it's like my own a s m r
the guy I like I put my own ASMR on
it's a is Samaras what it is it's just as
soon as early as tomorrow right
yeah I really like it though it makes me
happy
makes me feel cozy like my little plushie
here
Sam overnight
and we burned in I don't think this gets
burned in
was it changes it up pretty pretty regularly
we hadn't had any I hadn't had any bird in
far as I know
yeah I know but I don't believe it is it's
it's old but it's not that mean it's like 9
years old I remember the old stuff though
I'm at the I think it's French for today I
don't know
I told let's do this with some let's go
ahead and do the export now which I don't
remember how to do so if I remember right we
had to install rpcbind
which I think is already here yet or if you
see mind and nfsu tales
obviously buying is installed with nfsu
tells if I remember right so we can do our
PC info and see what we have
there we go
Pepsi infograph NFS I mean we got no and Fs
right now so
we need to turn an FS on
and I believe it's an FS server and I think
that's what we missed last time
an FS server
so I try that sooner systemctl and able to
stretch now which is a starts which is an
able and a start at the same time
service all systems you stuff
and I think rmfs should be there in a few
yet so that means that are NFS is listening
and now we have to update our Etsy exports
file it to have stuff in it
wanted on control Ivy primitive fire fights
we talked about so we got the end of his
server yeah we need to export
exports this is something I find interesting
I talked about
so I didn't want to know what should I
should I export the volume or the file
system
it's supposed to storm right so
and we'll just put sink here cuz I don't
want to get into we don't read right NSYNC
is a bunch of other options you can put
and the star which took me like 40 minutes
to find means exported to every every system
on the network
which means it's kind of a public thing
right
but it's okay because it's in a private
communities close to her so she should be
controlled
and then I heard they were supposed to do X1
FS Dash are again to get it exported I don't
know if that does anything that we have to
access the client and and and see what we
can do their Associates put this and go to
the client
oh you think
are we talking about the server and I got ya
thank you everywhere
we do near busy mind everywhere though right
okay
this is how you have it set up on your
server
nice if you guys have some of you have
knowledge on this would be really helpful
for me I don't do it very much though
vagrant worker won
and we're going to check ossh
I'm going to go check over here and see
what's up right so we should be able to make
a directory
local folder star a signal read squash I
forgot about no root squash thank you for
that
you're next when I first asked me to
double-check
if you put it to do here
yeah read write
sync no root squash
your voice of the cidr I know you can but I
don't
I don't because I wanted to be everything
actually no I know the cidr now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we know
this area right now because we recorded
thanks to b.g.
I forgot about that that's in our bigger
file now yeah so we are going to the eye
peas so we can actually put the 192 it said
you are in there
and call it a day
yes I'm glad I'm glad we're getting it later
because of this next step if I can get the
client setting up cuz we got to hard-coded
IP number which is normally wouldn't do you
have like a DNS probably for that but
but yeah
and then what. I can't use. Star
you can use that star I don't know if we try
that
it is 0 / 24
24 is a c i t r
Wait is riding that so I'll see that was
right at the right way
RN 22168 the 2.0 / 24 timing is everything
in the
everything in the end when I chill with you
say it. Tony that to network
it's 128 or sewing machines if we did I
think 16 it would be the two there'll be a
lot more machines
alright so
are we got and insulation absolutely yep
I would say is what you are. If you want to
learn his lesson although you could I mean
you can do it without aren't you could do it
you could do like a Gentoo as well
yeah if you want to suffer through the build
right
yes I'm trying to think if I would rather
you did me in for that
you can build like a assistant from Debian
from scratch as well right
Genji's for compiling if you want to get to
that point of it yeah
but I don't see what why not start with like
a really barebones Debian with no extra
stuff on it
yeah. Aren't you do you definitely read
about Administration yeah
so export FS svr
exporting 24 G / s
send a message to get to learn ya you know
what that's a good point I like Santa was
because it's your learning Enterprise skills
and it throws all the stuff in there that we
need to write sing to me the way I know tree
yes it does thank you very much yes
I feel like I need to write that one down I
knew it but is
I'm a big animal fan now after hearing
chunky has convinced me I used tires Alma is
is Alma
Steve Santos isn't dead it's a big myth
going to get Tony while riled up
it is kind of weird that they didn't show
that I thought they would
all right so now we need to mount that now
and we should be able to just mount it very
easily because it's so built in
right so we can say we should be able to
just mount
one night at sea 192.168
the 2.2 right
yep and then and then what am I going to do
colon slash ass en / us
then hit right I should probably put it as
being there I bet it's a firewall
I bet it's a firewall Astros last time
you're at the house what the fuck
that does not Inspire confidence it ain't
even wrong
shit
I mean no route to host client address.
Three
you told me to private network instead of
routing
I think it might be right look I thought it
was fine while the Nets and that is the kind
of thing I would have expected to be showing
up as a firewall
yeah I'm pretty sure primals on sitio status
and it's on at the firewall thing hey chunky
yeah I should have any of the false false
positive right
I want to say that that was yeah just keep
said that I understand
because it doesn't make any sense or wait
are we supposed to be rules
I think we're supposed to add that you
should be happy rules
o a r a i see what you're saying that's the
new thing you can tell me this week so
that's why I got used to it
I don't use it now it's now it's dead Jim
it's Emily dead Jim now
oh do I see resource busy and somebody in it
tree expert FS actually at use the old one
just fine
it's working now it was a firewall I'm going
back to the explicit when I like this one
better
this year did Xavier how's it going to miss
her extremely expert FS
the best Dash reload XSport at Fest Ashby
if it's ID option is zero isn't that nobody
you think I should be in the and exports why
should you die
no becauseno because I want to only slashes
is exported
yo are you telling me that so that would
that would export everything it's a new
thing and it's before I did not know that
was here we're trying to mount here
I'm getting device resource busy again
is it going to be based on I mean maybe
somebody's connected in there I don't know
unmount lazy
I mean why is it doing that oh no no no no
no no no I don't think any of us coming is
installed I don't think it is
no and if it is because nfsu2 else is on
both
yeah and if it still tells the number of
can I can you do this when you are PC info
and then pointed at this I think we can
I just want to check and make sure the nssf
is there
yeah it is I'll manifest up is there so
that's good we didn't get that before we did
not get that before try it whatever I say to
you you going to put that in the exporter in
the mount
so for the fsid in the mount or the export I
don't know
any actual game you guys are great
Mount Si oh my God it's already mounted
turkey mounted you already did it better
than automatically
holy shit in Mount it automatically when I
change it do you have to run mount
Ho Lee fuk it's working
I don't I don't understand why I started
working I dropped the firewall I just
started working with it because I already
put the mounts command in there
and it brought did added to the fs
interactionism out say whatever the nemesis
it's just a mountain
a backgrounds that it does OK that's exactly
what happened
yeah that's exactly what happened so that's
always busy it's already mounted
oh that's good news right so it says it
touch Foo
call Cesar Castillo Parts yes I yes I'm
learning that oh my God there we go there
was a small tear from the background
is there as wondering watch LS right
Touch another so it's making
it's making files across the system so over
here or on control and over here around
worker and it looks like we have the same
disk on both systems that's and if it's
working at tennis before only only on to
4019 CB that's what I thought it was
supposed to be
I don't know I just installed what they had
and it went over the bay so I don't even
know if this is right before I do I don't
even know how I know that
it does use our words
there is a version that uses 249 without rgc
there is definitely one because I read about
it because it says it's better to get
through firewalls
yeah I read something really briefly about
nfs3 all of this that said that there is
that the nfb for and if it's before is
better for firewall access because it's just
a single for a minute I think it's because
it's rose on her PC
and describing RPC to the average person is
beyond me irbc is a thing that makes up for
parts by providing more ports through and
another service and it's confusing as hell
it's a remedy from the old days I think it's
kind of dying out does anybody have any
reason to believe the RPC is actually being
chosen for new things I doubt very seriously
very seriously it is
I don't think it's going to be it's not
going anywhere because it's used for so many
things but applications didn't deploy a few
and far between
it's a saying Jeffy see the toy everything
I don't think jrpc uses our PC it's a
totally it's you just got the same name but
it's not the same at all the runaround for a
lot of things right there was xml-rpc for a
while and
and stuff
yeah I know that's why I'm saying so that's
why when you say the letters are PC they
mean different things to different people as
junkies telling you right now
and
that sounds like what I'm speaking about our
PC on the system it's it's a specific
implementation of an rpg-like thing that
distributes supports it handles that
limitation in port numbers for incoming
network connections and it's it's an extra
layer on top of the regular TCP IP port
thing and that's specifically what are PC
means when you're talking about it in this
case but it's gets use a lot to your PC has
nothing to do with the RPC that info stuff
that we were just using as a totally totally
different technology but shares the same
letters
so
and it's yeah I mean this is working so I
don't think we have to do now is figure out
a script that
bird of us exactly
of course I did all that is Route so let's
try it what happens I can I can I can I do
it without Root right I doubted
touch not route yeah I was afraid that
yeah I'm going to have to I'm going to have
to figure out how do you permissions and
stuff eventually
can we get something lost and found already
why do we have something most stuff out
already
it's not and you can turn on squash all
Cabarrus while we were good at it was either
Cabarrus or at some point we're going to do
identity management Rumpke absolutely yeah
I didn't even happen with the way it's this
way and is always goes and then if it's in
the book and everything I just I don't
necessarily want to get into identity stuff
now because I just want to set up an offense
without an identity stuff and that's one of
the biggest pain points are in a festive
getting all the identity shift to work so
right now I'm going to create processes that
fill the volume and do the testing all that
but I feel like we should at least make it
right it will buy anybody that has an ID on
the system
do you think we should just wash off and the
route I thought we did do squash all
I could have swore that we have a special on
oh I have no special yeah
yeah I think about making it here
yeah yeah I'm going to say
this one doesn't matter right this is a
review for me I don't remember remote
permissions that much I do know that you
guys can bathe at the biggest problem and
it's not a problem if you do if you know
what your ideas are
animator reacts part
that's not rude boo ya
well the other thing too is that these are
all
vagrant so the bigger user can share them
across all seasons
on the service of interesting yeah Lisa
Richards still yeah it'd be careful with
that to write because something that has 180
on one system I have a different idea in
another system
it's this or not contagious is different
base lamentation yes
Ivory rest is very different from what I
imagined you I'm not going to be looking for
gpsd anytime soon hey how's it going
I'm back b y u
b y u smile Mama do you know
yes sir I went to b y of the you you of the
b y
does it have any faster when you can have
the user to
I wonder if it comes with it by default I
don't know I don't think it does
yeah it's just it's just basically
information in this point this is final four
what I'm doing because everything just need
to be home by Meghan
so but however let's do this let's say SMUD
Simpson 7 / s
is it real that real you know truth is
serious can we got to do this if you if you
run an ex is there an export command that
does it and as it to the ATF
how do you do that is x 4 x 4 f s
I'mma ask for another one I'm an expert in
the MX sport you
and
smart 7077 webs slique
XSport slash you to everybody
God dammit I don't know how to do it
probably. I have no reason Xbox One command
line
yeah I know but I want to go to the Grand
containment are you fucking okay fine
you can do it that way I read about it
I read about it but I don't know if it has a
sexy exports I think we should just write it
stx46 yeah I agree I agree I agree I concur
because then it's like written some place
right
so it was due that looks right
Etsy exports oh God yes
I almost have this all entirely scripted but
she'll be so fucking awesome
do we only want to turn the firewall off on
the control box with Sam Smith I feel I feel
like we should poke holes but then I have to
do with our PC issue and all that
I I read I read documentation about how to
do that
about how to poke specific holes for it for
it you know I feel like that would be the
better thing to do but
I don't know yeah I want to hear
the prayers are working for me it is
for our PC it definitely is yeah
yeah efh I know if W I think it's a great
idea
I I like what you said there Ctrl firewall d
save all that starts now
all right I got that one off oh my God he
killed Lucy Lane
welcome welcome Raiders
we're planning to fails yeah I thought about
doing that as it going Christie welcome to
the party
yes we are having some fun here welcome to
svr already there you think there is it's
good to see you
let's see here so we've got what do we got
here we've got
we're just wrapping up this
and Through the Looking-Glass all that's
fine you can I mean it's just you know it is
what it is thank you for the fall
we have successfully mounted NFS from inside
of a vagrant configuration of virtual
machines if that sounds like absolute Greek
to you you know stay tuned and what kind of
kind of talk. But it's extremely extremely
happy moments you just joined us for he was
going to talk about so
actually we have
I don't even need to be right now anymore so
on the system this is a Unix system right we
have a directory called / s which is mounted
to a SASE be volume created by vagrants
volume that has a single large partition on
it just for the sake of consistency even
though we could do it with just this TV and
we melted it's just us with open permissions
and add it to our exports file and that
means that it's now available to any machine
on the network
I'm fine welcome and permanent answer to
Samba it is that exist for an FS
see if you can find Hilltop if you can find
that for infested be interesting I'd like to
try that
so so what does that mean that means that I
can see the engine / s and I can say
bar I can make a file here and then over
this is on control its on one machine and
this is on another machine both of them are
virtual machines on the same person at work
and you can see that bar exists over here
right and we're actually lucky here because
vagrant is the same you ID on user ID on
both machines because he's were both set up
with Baker and so able to have a bigger user
which makes it extremely convenient if we
were doing this we have to get kind of more
nitpicky about you know users and identities
and stuff like that and what has access to
that file system makes every but for the
sake of our testing hermanita
it's reload should be the same friend FS I
mean I'm I'm game we can try it
squash all the you IDs we did squash squash
off actually
yeah we turn a boy
directions to wash off here yes you did turn
it off cuz of God
it replaces artist NFS I mean if that works
I mean if that works I'm all for that do we
even have that thing farewell dashcommand I
guess we do
I mean let's try it let's listen to this
fire back up again where's the firewall
disable that I did
I feel you in here firewalls in here
somewhere
status is inactive she's dead Jim she's dead
Jim
is it too long it's all Harry Potter
or at it alright so
is there just replace status very welcome
and
I'm going to say enable dash dash now and I
wonder if we lost her access should we go
check
straight jacket we lost her access
oh my God we did no more access for us very
well just blocked our access
and that's cool that it's that easy to turn
back on that's going my name
weather some way to check this there so you
can run to check it to check your FS Mound
so I can't remember it it's it's it's
exported something
I can read I can I rent I just volume out
actually this is actually really really bad
so we're going to do the command hear from
our suggestion kill tops suggestion to
firewall-cmd permanent
add service in FS Horry sheet
do you need to restart it
didn't seem happy maybe I need a r e x for
it don't trust even yourself
gifts extreme trust zero trust restart the
service the NFL service or the firewall
okie dokie
and I haven't it I reread the news yet
search are you going to go see Ken
I like starts but there is you know for
certain things and what that search for
certain things
remount Dash you think we're doing this you
though we're doing a different one it worked
what I do it worked
it works it took a while but it did it and
then we did it
just wait the solution to everything wait
just wait a second god dammit
yeah there is huzzah I feel so much less
dirty doing that
who said that Hilltop you get VIP
Hilltop gets VIP for being awesome today
thank you for that. That was awesome is
awesome to Justin
so I feel so much less dirty yes
don't restart the service just reload Mount
that show reload
let's make of Heroes do so we need to
disable the service we can do this right now
damn it
Sea-Doo god dammit
symptom what is it say
alright so some of that restarts on failure
after several seconds I think you're
probably right yeah
can we look at the rules iptables save what
is that about
yeah
sure everyone except for word except
wow I didn't even have any of his stuff in
it
what that is confusing as hell to me
track my command reload oh yeah
so it's arranged yeah
that seems like a speed rack really fucking
permissive I don't know man I
I don't understand why it's so permissive
that's weird
anyway anyway I mean it seems to be at least
looks nicer
I still think it's kind of opening up the
kingdom to the two package you know
because our PC or maybe it's aware of any
death benefits before and if it's before
it's supposed to be a lot easier
so 50 export Jason
do you really need a Nifty non-fungible
token export
God damn is actually named entity I'm kind
of afraid
AJ Styles versus longer supported use I
hadn't what's entity do today I learned a
few thing
god dammit
and if any tables and family pack of
Michigan phone number I did not know it said
it was a thing
and if tables are you kidding me
is that the same thing like a dnf Thing 2
oh my God oh my God oh my God SM filter
Pharaoh Diaz using nftables that explains it
right so iptables is not to think I am so
embarrassed to admit today is the first day
I even heard any tables is a fucking thing
and if you breed a sign of Teas
2008 I'm so far behind I am so far behind
I feel ancient I know I got to be tables I'm
pretty well now they got any of these
used in ft and
what is the other one NFL
went to check the firewall Dash C MD
yeah one of the ten thousand
oh my God
checking to see changes to the fire to the
IP tables
alphabet
only to realize there didn't seem to be
anything if it seemed pretty permissive
though specific to a n f s in their turns
out
it was changing working package filters
fluid
let's roll set is that what it is
the new was it called its called
damn the new tables
which can be checked with a Nifty
oral sex more or less
it's Hills Dash hell thanks 2
Teva cept and you can
and twitch community I'm pointing this out
have no basis for that other than to know I
might try it right now while I'm thinking of
it so and if T list rule set
oh unexpected new line
this seems odd
oh dear
have completion Dash h
oh
no dashes
I'm trying to figure this one out to to to
to do
I heard HP directory Fallon command
nft when would you export
how are we do XSport Astrid s j
XSport I got the aquarium is pretty fun huh
I I stopped doing that all day though
because people were annoyed by the
notifications so rip fishies
what's up with this
I feel like I'm broke it somehow what did I
break break
there we go
everytable filters
yeah that's why I'm just as well figure this
out so yeah I'll put a changed
they sell chainsaw huh I pictures of still
think I figured it would be asking the
colonel that's pretty deep in that colonel
I'm guessing all the stuff and turn away is
not the same as the tools are changing again
I don't know that but I'm guessing
oh my God thank you for the reference
holyshit
as fucking huge this fucking huge
I want to I want to properly to this so I'm
going to book Market
and filters iptables project homepage in a
tablespoon of jacked
I guess that's fine
nice that's nice to know I feel instructed
by God damn I have learned so much today
from y'all I have I have learned a ton a ton
of God it's all written down it's going to
help will stink in
even if importation of filter sales it's
freezing at Bridges woo
anacyclus website
what's that you know the surf browser I have
not heard about the surprise yet I think I
haven't heard about that now
not the way I thought they all my God me too
well I saw the infrastructure stuff right
but I'm going to repeat what I said earlier
the calendar is being
restricted I'm chopping back all the
material I'm going to try to cover in my
boots education stuff to
Lennox and coding specifically for Lennox
coding operation stuff infrastructure
Engineering in containers communities that's
all you're going to see me stream about in
an education capacity on Saturday so I'll do
a lot of other fun stuff but but that's the
only educational content are going to see
from me no more sea coding will will touch
on sealcoating during a structure
engineering wake up when we talked about
system calls and it's trace and stuff like
that going to cover pointers and a little
bit of sea and go in the coating part of the
universe but video where a lot of scripting
language structure engineering to
so there's the the Boost if you want to keep
track of it
and a few new people in here so
if you want it you want to keep track of
what's going on tomorrow is ama ama today
pretty much all day as well since we've been
going so I do want to spend some time with
my wife though
ansible absolutely ansible terraform vagrant
they're all going to be covered
get bigger and I know it's old but you know
it still has value virtualbox virtualbox
Liberty moo KVM all that stuff goes under
that probably proxmox or something like that
set up local cloud
is it affect the infrastructure engineering
could be mostly about virtualization almost
all because virtualization is the best way
to test network engineering and a lot of the
count so so so yeah
Zoom that back out
over to silvergate yes yes I kind of want to
look at that too because there's just so
much to cover their
you know I will command
that filter is used Bass for actual hooks
really
God damn it again so just I don't know
something just does a bunch of server use it
and using it filter
Curtis there is a red hat Enterprise thing I
think it's another situation situation we're
picking red-headed so is a wise choice for
Enterprise
they all do it doesn't make sense because we
were looking at iptables stuff on our honor
apt stuff
is it going to rain thing interesting I must
have had an older Colonel then
I can't remember where it was but I thought
we were using a table and some the other day
and I can't remember what it was
it was one of the containers that we were
doing
I appreciate your thinking
Abalone Farmall they're
apparently it's been around for a long time
okay I did not know I did not know this is
what happens when you get away from it
before to engineering is to become a coder
self now I know
Suddenlink I want to adhere y'all are giving
me Great Lakes I got to Adam
1998 fuck I don't believe you
I was done using it filter anyway I'll tell
you that I'll be able to start using a table
to like 2,000
oh my God I'm not listing Wikipedia yeah
right on that, I don't know but the
knowledge base is pretty good yet the Reddit
Engineers are good there's no doubt about
that the redhead company the engineer is
amazing
your buggy service don't have no filter or
see that's okay now I'm I feel Justified
I'd like to make a conclusion that yet
another reason to use that had for your
Enterprise simulations is 2 is that filter
I'm actually going to put that in my list of
notes I I didn't respond I didn't know about
red hat and why you should use it for
Enterprise simulation and that's one of them
so
yeah
you tell me what all goes in a filter even
though it's a shame
I've seen people saying that they needed to
look Beyond in filter
where where was that that's where I saw it
that's where I saw it
that was in the NFL supporting and said you
needed to be able to plug in for beer and
air filter
yeah BP folder
yes doctor sometimes when I should be there
in that folder that was what I saw yeah it's
Four Bridges yes if that's a specifically
that's miss it was a wizard Vigor an ansible
thing
now that there was there was definitely
something we were doing where we had to add
BR filter to a to a plug-in thing
I can't remember that was alright so
so we're about ready to test this thing and
it will be my final test for the day we're
going to actually run this entire
provisioning just by running vagrant up and
by the end of it we should have a working
NFS exported and mounted in the clients
and we need to do that so
so else if it's not a control then we should
be doing what we should be make sure / s
and we should dude be doing I think if we if
we if we call Mount should we call him out
or so we put in the office to have
call Matt alike hang around forever but it
should be the first one
mounts I'm going to do it I don't care
mount 192.168
Express SOS Mi yes thank you
navigate to Mount 118 at 168 dot 2
at 2 1 / s / s
yeah
internal with a V PS4 compiled in that
folder is also do it with me I'm pretty sure
it was a colonel modplug in the bridge was
the colonel not plugging that we had to add
for
something we were doing with a virtual
machine and live Birds it was part of
actually yes it was a part of liver thing
and we got around it and we just used the
docker we just use the doctor image for
Baker into that was what it was so if it
gets you just watching this for the first
time and you don't know nothing about
vagrant if you want to use liver with
vagrant just use the docker image
and run it because it has all of the crazy
ass live bird stuff including the bridge
netfilter stuff built-in we tried to do all
that stuff without it and it was a pain in
the ass and then I had to throw out the
doctor and I started going cuz I can I
change my provider for living for Baker and
back to virtualbox and I started to use
another Ruby file now direct and haven't had
any problems so far it's slower and slower
but because there were two boxes Luxor
if I think I'm provisioner is kind of ready
imma go ahead and close these
and I'm going to start this and if this
actually works we are golden for the evening
so I mean I get this is super exciting I
like that we can provision a kubernetes
cluster
I'm sorry A system that in the virtual
machines be able to run this vagrant file is
going to allow anybody with 8 quarters or
more and 60 MB of ram to instantly start
with the Baseline machines necessary to
install kubernetes from scratch on Prem and
to do that training her throw it away and do
it again and that is fucking crazy exciting
to me because this is the kind of thing you
need to practice all the time and super
excited about this start messing around abpf
I know it's funny you said that that was my
first concern is like user is allowed access
dppf
yeah yeah it's very interesting all right
let's do this let's go for this
dude I think I think we're good to go yeah
kind of a Bosch I just say I really love it
install nfsm client
and use a space you want to try it so we do
it it's going to take awhile
I was going to tell you if you take a while
to run
I got to destroy a destroy
God all the time
no I actually do want to do it right now if
I can get this to work I'm literally done
with this you realize what the next
thing is going to be
speedrunning installation of kubernetes as
fast as possible now that's now that's
something you'll see me Speed Run you'll
never see me speedrun veeam than tutor but I
tell you what I definitely will Speed Run
kubernetes installation from scratch
I'm going to do it I'm going to get it I'm
going to get so fast yeah
because yeah I'm not going to keep straight
at all that's what this is I'm not using you
because it keeps freezing Cloud thing
yeah it's been for the last week have you
really I know I want to be I want to get so
good to be able to get ready so that I can
Social Securities that I can do it we could
be DM on it on on a to note cluster I'm
sorry I had to work or you know single oak
cluster in like with a CLA and the network
provisioner and everything and podracing I
want to be able to do all that and just like
boom boom boom boom just be able to do that
and also everything and then it build
applications for it right
I just finished lunch and yeah if you I
still wanted to answer a phone do me wrong
but Victor is definitely to go to tool for
this thing even though I started out with a
love-hate relationship with it
I see it was a Tas what's a Taz animal that
is I don't know what that is
the second some information or anything
vagrant to assisted speedrun
okay is that a thing
so we have learned so much just by sitting
up this vagrant file I have learned so very
very much game consoles
it was how he was going to be around yeah we
need to get until 6 this morning
this weekend I mean the next step is to
write a shell script that that up to your
cooler that is closer like that I'm going to
do the upping of my kubernetes cluster I'm
trying to make a different Meghan file
that's why I separate out the slab by the
way so you know our Labs right this lab is
just setting up in a s that's all it is
and then I don't want to include that
material you know that education material in
the communities thing I'll say hey go look
up how to set up an FS right and then
CC I'm saying if you just want to set up an
FS you can go through this and then you can
go sit on top of my NFS and then we can
combine the labs and composing together
that's kind of like a, like the goal
yeah
I'm so excited about this so because this I
have been so stressed about how to how to
learn kubernetes without paying Cloud money
in there it is here it is right here
it is if you want to learn kubernetes and
you don't want to pay a fucking dime and you
want to actually use cover letters instead
of instead of Mini Cooper kind which
technically are kubernetes even though you
can't do things with them you can't test
city of your own storage provider you can't
test you know those things I mean you
probably can it was just you just be have to
really really do it weird
kubernetes uses you in Russia what's faster
Gen 2
oh my God emerge world
I don't know how long it's going to take who
is there anybody ratable up right now
do to do to do
what sometimes I wonder why I follow people
what if I fall
to to to to to to to do I'm just watching
this
what the hell
everybody wants to know what is you talkin
about I'm not saying
oh my God
I come on you know it I can't complain cuz
this is still much faster than it would ever
take me to do other stuff
how did they move their closed captioning
oh my God it's a plug-in
there's a there's a closed captioningclosed
captioning plug-in you can get
it's way way better than the built-in one
shit
did you guys see this is it closed
captioning plugin
this is why I watch other streamers I get
good ideas from
yeah there is totally a closed captioning
plug in
okay so cool
all right I just see it shows much more of
the stuff on the screen and it also allows
you to move it around and change your font
this one says it's called stream closed
caption ER
stream closed captioner I didn't know that
was a thing I just used to play no closed
caption button from twitch.
But I think I want to go add that
it doesn't like standard though but it's
definitely prettier on the screen
I'm sure I know there's a lot of different
ones to but
it's so much better because it looks like 20
lines on the screen so you can write a font
really small
yeah just kidding sizing on right now
so and I'll show you this or waiting for
this run first contestant on Chicot and that
cool
I'm really jealous for kittens of your CC
and BCC plug-in cell
ain't nothing I don't know about this I was
it drops the standard CC down here you just
have this only right I wonder if you cannot
do both of them
you know so
a girl
she must have box always seems to pick his
favorite
Debby Ryan
I can get about working good
somebody to look at font awesome because I
thought about putting I love font awesome
God damn that brings back memories
I have a celebrity phone oh I want to make
sure it works and I'll push it
then I will push it how to make a drum roll
I have to make I have to do things besides
communities like Adam Oates to my stream I
don't have the most on my stream yet
I really want to add him
it's like one of those like crazy things
I'll do when I'm like drinking or something
instead of play DotA
I haven't heard back from banana soap banana
went to Disney and they said they said that
she send me theirs had a message anywhere
just scored
I thought because I have caption right now
but it's like the old school one in most you
can get is like four lines I love that you
can like set your van sir
attention Scott description no it is not
which is why it hasn't happened
I know I like the most boring story ever I
however CC matters CC matters because people
can put me on at work and they can watch the
screen and do what the fuck is you doing and
they can chime in when they when they have
something interesting to see
yeah I mean and that's how I watch other
people I always have a streamer O2 on I
always really have like one or two streamers
on and in another in another window then I'm
just watching to see what they're doing
yeah inside the baker file I did not know
that
how did you do that
recommendations on streamers in my list you
know most of the strippers and recommend
don't seem very much had Tanis is probably
my the closest to me whenever head is on if
I'm not screwing me and watching me that
tennis
h e t underscore t a n is he does he does
Enterprise stuff he's certified in multiple
platforms and
what flushed face
holy shit why am I not doing that why am I
doing that
I'm at the game I knew at that right now I
have to add that
complete all right so we test it and then
fix it or should I fix it first all right
I'm going to add this
how do I how do I do I do it I don't know
how to do environment variables in Ruby I'm
sorry
EnV vagrant
energy grab bag
okay so I can we change these Envy
is it safe yet
is that right
experimental I don't know why I didn't know
that
it doesn't look happy that's very Pearl like
I feel like we have to change that now make
it right
what's the NFL some bigger machines about
your going to see it's for its for testing
setting up of NFS and for practicing
communities deployment to the storage class
that uses going too fast so I can fill up
fill it up and watch it blow up and then try
to prevent that that's why
so I thought you would never do it in real
life at me for anything practical but it's
great for development
midna specifically we had Domino's in case
you don't know Domino's a coordinated
application right and get ready we have
Domino blow up because the volume dinner
lying NFS volume filled
from a bunch of backups are doing it filled
and it killed Domino and this whole this
whole thing came about from my work
requirement to figure out a way to be warned
when I specifically a PVC is running out of
space and then I won't get into the details
about her that isn't Cooper news because
there's no concept of Field disc and
kubernetes at all
so
and it can become sort of a storage is
supposed to be infinite to not supposed to
care about how close you are to getting full
and that's that's not a kubernetes concerned
that's assistance concerning and so I've
been exploring different ways of of of being
worn specifically was sending a single
messages and so this particular project is
setting up all the stuff for an internal
companies cluster with a tiny NES will tend
to get megabytes on it that I can fill in a
controlled environment wouldn't even do that
in staging you know that would not be
something I want even to say to you so and
it and then I want to send a message on
possibly created a internal Cron job or an
external Cron job that monitors those
Dismount points in NFS just using it to you
or do you have for something and then and
then giving us a kind of threshold warning
in a single so that that all of that shit is
really hard to test and even a development
to raise environment
because I can't mess around with store
classes and make new ones and stuff like
that and I can't you know so that's where
this all comes from
if your if you want to create a allow that
you can read to a really quickly and early
fuck around with then this is the way to go
it really is
it go I really is
I'm about to prove it so vagrants God I hope
this works please let this work I didn't see
any like outstanding the error messages so I
think we're good
maybe get rid of that one annoying warning
to LPG
was that one in Orem and worry and kept
hitting me with I think it's gone night to
now
yeah it's a sage worker
if it's works we should be able to see Dean
2 / s touch Foo
and then they Grinch SSH into work or two
and seating is / s and it's there oh my God
we got it on the first shot if we tried it
on the first shot how rare is that how rare
is that oh my God who
hello there and this cat food
ekco fine
tifu cat food
makes me so happy you have no idea how happy
I am right now oh God damn it I know what
the tiny thing in the rest of your like oh
my God this guy but that is such a huge
thing to be able to do that to be able to
set up your own contained NFS multi-node
environment is just just just ripe with
possibilities I just have so many things I
want to do with this now so I am saving this
shit right now
yeah it doesn't happen if there's lots of
other things that didn't work on the first
try so we did all of these things we did all
these things I need to clean up the task in
here
I said for sure
/ asteroid rectory and Extras volume and
explored I didn't buy him it's a file system
that's it
we are done this project done I just need to
clean up the reading and stuff and we can
come back to this guy
Simmons find son work
and yeah I'm going to clean this up and
we'll put it into a better lab environment
but if if you want to retry this I encourage
you to try to do everything in the read me
on your own without help and then if you
want to look through to see the answer you
can you can come in and do the actually want
to move this over
move solution until our work and have an
issue I want to add there
I don't know right man didn't clean up the
read me remove related
that lady stuff into the work notes
readme.md instead so as to not give up
solution and clutter
misread me. You're probably going to be
around later but if you are I have the rest
of the night I want to talk about the
knowledge exchange red and I want to talk
about how to set up these Labs because I'm
making so many of them though I kind of want
to standardize on it
some of that issue
status statues holyshit this is not a game
commit complete
working solution needs move to work
alright so
I wantwait what
do to do to do nice to see everybody going
to kill this turn L2
so here is the repo
if you want to see this if you want an FS
set up the next step is going to be
integrating this into the kubernetes set up
so that I'm I'll be ready to go to set up my
own communities volume appreciate all you do
here I think we'll go ahead and read for a
kitten
so
bomba bomba do do but that is good hey
thanks for that follow
please please give my best to First kids I'm
not going to be around so I told him I'd
tell her I'm out eating by
do to do to do